This is Jocko podcast number one 82 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good evening. Good evening.
The insertion was flawless.
We were in the woodline and on our way for a general area reconnaissance.
This time we played it by the book moving 10 minutes than waiting 10 minutes.
As we moved, I swore that I'd never run an eight man team again.
It's too cumbersome in this target.
The vegetation still made me a tad on edge as it had a second canopy in some
areas, but still gave us long lines of sight, something we weren't used to
as darkness approached. We looked for a good spot to Ron
with the flat terrain finding a good Ron became really dicey.
Ordinarily we'd look for high ground dense vegetation or an area far from any
trail. Finally, we found one and south set up a perimeter,
set up the watch rotation and oversaw the placement of extra claymore mines in
one area where the vegetation was thin.
Bubba placed a couple of toe poppers in the ground. I couldn't sleep.
The flat terrain played on my mind before first light.
The entire team was awake, alert,
retrieving the claim or minds and preparing for our move out of the Ron.
After a night on the jungle floor,
I wanted an rnr anywhere with firm beds, clean sheets,
and cold drinks because I insisted on carrying the PRC 25 there was little room
in my backpack except for essentials at night when I slept on the ground,
I did so without an air mattress or hammock.
The sole item of comfort was an army issue,
pullover sweater that buttoned up to the neck.
Whenever I put it on at night.
I was always worried about Charlie hitting us when I was pulling the sweater
over my head.
It was one of the few creature comforts I allowed myself or had room for in my
rucksack.
All right.
Shortly after first light,
the Green Horn at c aircraft flew into the edge of our AOL for a routine camo
check. I gave him a quick team. Okay.
And prepared to move the team out of the Ron. However,
the CNC crew told me to wrap up the mission.
There was another problem that he couldn't discuss on an open frequency.
We knew the NVA monitored SOG, FM radio transmissions,
and had radio direction finding equipment.
The CNC pilot told us to find an El z and let and to let them know when we'd be
ready for extraction. A few minutes later,
the Green Hornets roared into the new LC, picked us up and returned us to base.
The reason we were yanked from the field this time stemmed from a tragedy in the
prairie fryer area of operations.
On 30 November an age 34 king bee was shot out of the sky during an son.
Operation Seven Green Berets from fob one and fob four were killed when an
antiaircraft round struck the Sikorsky chopper and ignited the ammunition on the
aircraft killing everyone on board.
One of the men killed and that ill fated King Bee was staff Sergeant Arthur e
Bader.
I liked Bader on my last night at fob one before shipping out to fob six I
played in a poker game where he won a lot of money.
The longer we played, the more money Bader won,
the more money Bader won, the more morose he became.
Yeah.
At one point I asked him what was wrong.
He was winning and he was a head several hundred dollars,
but kept complaining that he'd never spend the money.
His response was that he had a premonition that he was going to die and that men
about to die often when a lot of money, money that they would never spend.
We all tried to Josh amount of his dark mood but failed.
Cool Bader
was a unique special forces green baret he had earned and lost three separate
fortunes in between three terms in the service.
He was in his thirties but still enjoyed SF,
spoke fluent German and a few other languages and merely wanted to accomplish
any mission assigned to him
on the flight on the long flight back to fruit by,
I kept hearing him talk to us at the poker table that last night.
Yeah,
now he was gone.
Okay.
Now he was gone and that
is the reality of war captured in the best selling book across the fence
and back with us again to talk about war is the author of that book and of
another book called on the ground and have a series of books called the sock
chronicles,
a man who has seen more than most and who has had more close calls than any man
should have.
Okay.
John is Stryker Meyer and if you haven't listened to podcast one 80 and one 81
yet,
go back and listen to them first to hear the background of this hero,
this warrior special forces soldier and leader of our t Idaho,
a recon team for Mac v SOG working missions across the border from Vietnam into
Laos and Cambodia. John, good evening, sir. Good evening.
Thanks for coming back again.
Glad to be back every time you walk out of the studio.
About 10 minutes later I said you had a tech say, hey,
can you come back again next week? We just have so much fun.
I can't say no that's happened. That's just that happened. That's both.
That's how you ended up here. Again, every time you walk out of here I go,
I want to hear you talk more. Oh,
hear more about what you've done and yeah, no, it's a, it's been awesome.
And the response from people have been hitting me up. There've been, uh,
just just enthralled with what you've been talking about and hearing,
hearing you tell these stories has been, has been interesting.
And you, you haven't seen this.
Have you heard of a movie character named Jason Borne?
Have you heard of this guy? Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
So I posted a picture of you when you were 21 or 22. I think you were 22.
He's my illegitimate son. Yeah, they, they,
you've got some definite comments about that. Interesting.
So yeah, we got there. The real guy back again. So
I know we have that first excerpt that I just read was from across the fence and
I wanted to go back to your other book for a little bit,
the book on the ground and then I just want to,
I got a bunch of things I want to just to ask you about. And talk to you about,
but I wanted to cover one more section of this book on the ground.
I was reading through it again yesterday and it's just again,
one of these situations where
I don't know how you're here right now to be honest with you buddy Grayson guy.
Indeed. To become guides to smarter our team. And you know,
you guys had more than a hundred percent casualty rate. Correct.
You had guys that, you had some guys that had seven, eight, nine purple hearts.
Bob Howard was put in for 11 he only received eight and my case,
I've been put in for two more for just shrapnel. You know,
you look at guys who get two legs blown off arms pla office,
like almost embarrassed to take it and anybody got a purple heart in our day.
You got really ragged for it, you know, cause they you dumb ass,
you just couldn't get out of the way fast enough. She got a purple heart.
Yeah. I think we had one of my old Vietnam seal buddies,
I think he called it the v the Vietcong achievement medal was the purple heart.
That's a good one. I like that. Uh,
so you were put in for two more. How many did you get already?
Oh, it's that one. Okay. And again, spider parks and pat walk-ins. My, you know,
my gurus, my recon Gurus, uh,
we had one that had been put in for just minus Rapinoe.
The paperwork disappeared.
[inaudible] another one have more shrapnel and this time was a little bit,
a lot more serious bleeding and scratching and stuff. Little blood.
But I think serious compared to what guys, for sure they really get hammered.
They said no put in for it. Someday you may have to go to the VA and to his VA.
Even though the benefits, it's there, you'd get home loans. Oh,
okay. I might be a future if we get through. There might be a future
set that had still pays 22, Tom After three purple hearts. Was that a rule?
No, that's this room out of sock. What about a normal,
what about a normal soldier? I wouldn't know.
I never spent any time in a regular unit or, yeah, no. I mean Bob Howard,
he took his age and he should have had 11 all the cluster. They just,
they ran out of clusters for those. Yeah, and you talk about [inaudible]
calls volume one. What was it? 16 guys went out.
16 special forces soldiers went out and they got 33 purple hearts in four days.
Oh yeah. It probably could have gotten more. Sure. Ridiculous.
Absolutely is crazy. Yeah. Yeah. All right. We're going back to all that.
The ground. Here we go. The Hueys lifted off,
made a gentle lazy turn and pointed their noses northwest.
Once everyone was settled,
I allowed my mind to wander as I looked out and marveled at how beautiful
landscape was from several thousand feet up in the air up where it was open and
cool rather than closed in Magee,
there was also a sense of inner peace and pride.
This is what I had volunteered and trained so hard for this chance to run top
secret missions behind enemy lines, dangerous missions that made a difference.
Like most special forces types.
I couldn't stomach the monotonous routines of camp life,
the ash and trash detail stuff. The petty rules, regulations,
formations and egos
more amazing.
Yet here I was at the ripe old age of 22 sporting the exalted rank of e four and
the one zero of ASOG recon team 22 years old.
Young and dumb. Yeah. 22 years old. And you'd been bust if you hadn't been,
you got busted down once or twice. Only once. Okay.
So you would have been an e five you think at this point?
Oh would have been up must of powerful. Yes. At least to me
that must've been car crazy cause usually you got promoted based on a,
if you're running missions whenever the appropriate timeframe was to be in one
grade before you be considered for the next saga was really good about getting
the promotions. At least our people are.
So as soon as you accomplish your time in rank, you get one from me,
deuce e four really quick.
So yeah.
When you this,
this idea of being an SF and just being on camp and on base and having the
normal kind of routines, you just couldn't stand that. No.
You just would rather be out in the field.
Oh yeah. It just drives you nuts,
Jack. All right, here we go. Back to the book. I had been with Archie,
Idaho for seven months now by dent of hard work, lots of mission experience,
and simply having survived. I was now a team leader at moment's notice.
I could have millions and millions of dollars worth of air support assets,
some of them manned by majors and lieutenant colonels all doing my bidding,
all giving their courageous best to save my bacon.
I'd come a long way since flunking out of college and doing a stint as a garbage
collector and Yosemite National Park Park.
My egotistical reveries were cut short when the door gunner on my side of the
Huey decided to cut loose with a long burst of [inaudible] machine gun fire
right next to my ear. Fortunately, he was simply test firing it.
You're, you know, we would get,
I guess kind of similar is we'd be driving to a target, right?
Being in a home v, you know, sometimes the targets are an hour,
sometimes two hours. You know, we did some long, long transits,
but you would get time to sit there and think about stuff because well you're,
you're sitting there and being transported. There's not too much you can do. Um,
you know, you're scan and you're looking for, but you were in a helicopter.
There's nothing to do but think really.
It was always amazing cause it's just so beautiful.
I mean Southeast Asia from the air, even when you went over to combat zone,
you see the bomb craters and he, but the jungle, it was just,
just beautiful country.
And then you get under it and get into the underbelly of the jungle disliked.
Oh, so you notice it does a whole world, the starling contrast, you know? Yeah.
And like if you're in the desert,
it has its own beauty and it can be spellbinding if you just watch it a little,
wow. Look at this.
That without realizing that somewhere there's a little hole so a guy could pop
out of the hitch with an RPG or detonate. And in your case,
does remote controls your, when you roll over,
did you,
it sounds like you recognize this when you were doing these operations,
you kind of knew that this was,
I don't know, I guess I'm going to use this word, you are lucky to be there.
Oh clearly.
Cause I 100% when I was in Iraq and I only did two deployments to Iraq,
I 100% knew every day that I was there.
I knew that this was
okay.
Like my time, this is what I'd been like, this is what I will live for.
And I knew that it wasn't like I look back and say,
oh well I really wish I would have appreciated those days. No.
When I was in them I completely knew it and appreciated being there like every
single day.
Yeah. And I,
it was a nice feeling personally to think that here we are with the best of the
best and we're running into missions and that's what we live for is, okay,
now we're here.
Let's go do this and just hope,
get the mission done.
And just was the Dan trackers who leave you alone as he get the mission done.
Good. Do to wire tap or snatch a pow, something like that. Oh yeah.
It felt good, but you know, it's like quiet professionals.
You just don't talk about that much. Yeah.
Going back to the book, as we approached the LZ,
the team crowded the two doors of the helicopter.
I was on the right half standing on the skid. Sal was kneeling behind me.
His hand on my shoulder ready to follow me out.
The door next to him was Hep my one one John Bubba shore.
Along with Foc, our point man and Twan are grin.
A deer got ready to exit out the left side door.
We all kept our eyes riveted on the looming jungle scanning for any signs of
movement in the treeline surrounding our LZ,
the top of the triple canopy growth of trees,
vines and other vegetation was at least a hundred feet off the jungle for.
And the opening into which we were descending reminded me of the mouth of a long
dark tunnel at the bottom of which resided things alis never dreamed of when she
tumbled into that rabbit hole of hers.
As we were swallowed up and the darkness increased,
a cold chill ran down my spine.
Okay.
When you're going into these spots,
so you had pre identified this El z prior to, is that correct?
At that point we were working with Covey at Dorn debriefing.
We give out the officials, uh, LZs, you know,
the primary secondary alternate [inaudible] and that would go to Saigon.
Then we in his year find something else because we knew the servers,
it was corrupt.
And then so by find something else,
you're basically just looking for a clearing of some kind. That's right. Right
within that, within that target. And usually to be somewheres else,
say go somewheres, we're Saigon,
the leek deer wouldn't get the word back cause we had that one target.
We went in with the bomb.
The LZ was literally wired and a top streak awardee had wire already with a 500
pounder. So, uh,
we were beginning to do that much more often than could. We had good,
great copies. They knew what we,
the key, the cab,
the cubbies fly the area of operations before you inserted on the day before or
anything like that.
Well during the day up they will just fly over it. Sure.
Where they just pictures or anything? No, no. Uh,
usually they just do a VR visual reconnaissance and they would try to be subtle
about like an early 68.
We always flew a visually causes prior to the mission and the NVA is not stupid
there. If they see a bird dog flying over targeted, they figure,
well pretty soon we're going to get visitors and sure enough,
so that gave them time to get ready.
So we basically cut out dvrs on our part.
And then when cubby go out, you know, a lot of these guys have been flying,
they're more familiar with the ego, the VR with a helicopter on. Oh No.
Usually with a South Vietnamese air force,
they'd have a little a oh one. Oh. Just like from World War II.
The one from the battle from the bowls were Henry Fond.
It's up there in the right seat.
And a pilot's got this little cub piper cubs going 88 miles an hour top speed
downhill. Yeah. Yeah. And that's what, and uh,
so that would be most of our vrs,
but then by Christmas we pretty much cut that out.
Okay.
Yeah. And that just cause they were, they, that was given away, you know,
we used to ride on logistics air and kind of move the logistics air a little bit
to go over an area that we're going over.
So no one would know that we were in there, that we were taking pictures,
you know, like just logistics air, just to an aircraft flying somewhere.
They'd go in a straight line. They wouldn't, they'd just veer off a little bits.
We could see what we wanted to see.
Sure. And then also did the fake fake inserts. Um,
sometimes they didn't have the fuel to do a lot fake inserts,
but they had a device called the Nightingale where they would go in,
go to Nightingale, often pull the a detonator on it and it was,
sounded like a firefight so that would have a lot of commotion and then they
would jump up, go to a second LZ and, and put us in at down south.
We were with the, uh, the greenhorns. They,
they really had a cold cause it was flat down, up, down, up.
So at the NVA were trying to guess which of the three or four touchdowns where
we were, they were really busy.
Got It. Going back to the book as the chopper near the jungle floor,
Bubba and I executed our first standard operating procedure,
which was checking the LZ for trip wires or booby traps while the rest of the
team's search the surrounding jungle for any signs of trouble.
After giving the all clear, the team was out the doors.
And all on the ground before the skids firmly touchdown.
How long would you hover there and look at the LZ for? Oh, not long.
Like a matter of 10 seconds
and just like you guys would go in God's down, get out.
Sure. Yeah. We used to just jump out,
lay down like the helicopter would just touch and take off it.
We would just jump out, lay down right there. We wouldn't move away from it.
Just jump out and laid out a modern day version of touching gum. Yeah. Yeah.
We quickly headed to the woodline and set up a provisional perimeter where we
could wait and listen.
Yeah.
When again, we saw on her, nothing suspicious.
We burrowed deeper into the jungle where as both dancer and darker,
like some furtive predatory animal,
we were looking to hide ourselves after 10 minutes of no threatening sounds or
movements.
I radioed Covey and gave him the message he had been waiting to hear Timo K he
and others could take up breathing again. At least for the time being.
Yeah.
The deeper we moved in the deep we move,
the darker and more claustrophobic things became moving through.
The foliage was an excruciatingly slow and painful process with sweat,
stinging one's eyes, bugs,
crawling and feasting upon exposed skin and visibility cut to mere feet.
Okay.
It could also be disorienting,
especially when the maps we were given were so useless.
And here was our t Idaho looking for fuel lines.
Some bright eyed Covey writer had spotted and directed airstrikes against
intelligence reports said there was a second pipeline in this EO as well.
Regardless of how many, any pipeline we found we were going to destroy.
And what were the map? Would you have one to 50 maps? Is that what you had?
Yeah, one to 50,000
right. But they would cut out from the big map.
They would cut out like a 10 by 10 or 12 by 12 square so that if we were killed,
they came across the map to be no other Intel on a separate at one targeted that
we were on the ground.
Now I've gone into triple canopy jungle before with one.
You ever had seen a one to 24 map?
They're basically more detailed duress. They're twice as detailed.
They're pretty good. But one to fifties are not that accurate.
No. Then we had that one target where they had forgotten a mountain. You know,
we're on a mountain and we're getting ready to go down the go over and we look
at it as like, Hey, you forgot one that really could stretch your Mitch and out.
When you're in triple canopy
claustrophobic, you use that word claustrophobic quite a bit in this section.
Is this jungle just tight?
Very. Yeah. Because again,
sometimes you had to keep sight on the guy in front of you as you moved, uh,
because you just become separated so easily because of the dense vegetation.
Of course. A lot of times, um, our Vietnamese were shorter.
They get through a cricket. Well, we would be down on our knees. I'd be,
I wore out more pants crawling through the jungle.
I know. I saw a picture. I was looking at the pictures in the books.
I saw a picture of one of the indigenous that some of those guys were really
small. Oh yeah. Really small.
98 pounds soaking wet, but 50 pounds of heart.
Oh, that's awesome. All right. Going back to the book,
but I had more immediate and pressing concerns.
The adrenaline rush that always accompanied it and insertion had pretty much
worn off and another characteristic sensation had begun to take its place.
It was a feeling of familiarity and comfort combined with an eerie sense of
foreboding. Both were a product of experience.
I was comfortable because I was surrounded by extraordinary well trained and
fiercely devoted team that knew what it was doing yet.
We also had stepped in enough accidental shit and had encountered so many
hostile enemy units that it was impossible to not feel serious anxiety.
In fact, I figured that when I stopped being scared Shitless,
I would be on my way to buying the farm.
Cockiness had cost more than one life.
So you still,
you get that little mixed feeling of comfort but fear and anxiety at the same
time.
Yes. You know, you like the whole adrenaline of, you know how it is inserted,
you're just pumped and at some point you get off,
you get on the ground sell downs. You guys would hit so many times, you would,
you would insert immediately get contacted a lot of, yeah. So
once it'd be amped up, going in,
and then when there's nothing there that starts to fade. Yeah.
Then you finally get on the grass like, oh, at last we're on the ground.
Now let's get on with the mission. Worry about the trackers, let's get moving.
But let's also stay cognizant,
keep our situational awareness tight and that, you know, this is a,
one of the reasons I highlighted this section is, you know,
just this is something that, you know what,
we talk about complacency all the time.
I know there was a number one of the Marine Corps units, we were with the,
the three, eight and Ramadi, they had a bed aside.
They had signs around their compound. Complacency kills. Yeah, for sure.
But this idea of they knew,
I also talked to young military guys, young seals that, you know, they're,
they're scared of this. They're scared of. That's like, I always tell them good.
You know, you should, you should be afraid you.
Cause if you're afraid you're going to prepare more,
you're going to train harder. You're going to,
you're not going to cut any corners. You're not going to get complacent.
And that's the same thing that you're saying here is you'd seen cockiness cost
people their lives cause they think, oh we can just get away with whatever.
Yeah. If you're not scared, I'm scared of you. Really?
Yeah. Yeah. And then you have to overcome that though,
cause you can't let that get, get controlling you.
We were talking before we started recording and we were talking about a guy that
was in a firefight. There was one guy that didn't fire a shot,
stayed curled up in a ball praying. Yeah. That's when,
that's when fear is not good. Not your friend,
your arc guys wanting to shoot him.
So you got to balance that. You got to be, you got to have the fear.
You got to feel it, but you got to deal with it. Correct.
We had campuses so we knew the general direction we were headed,
which was to the northwest, away from the LZ.
We had been working our way slowly through the underbrush for about an hour when
suddenly we heard an explosion behind us.
It had to have been the claim or bubba rig to go off.
If anyone tried to follow us off the LZ,
it's detonation single signaled a profound change in the situation.
The hunters were about to become the hunted in the jungle.
There are almost always animal noises of some kind and these suddenly fell
silent in the quiet.
We could hear some distressing sounds to the west sounds that were not of a
jungle kind, but those of men on the move.
Okay.
We were not alone.
Welcome to the jungle baby. Yes,
indeed. That, uh,
how do you know that the claymores that you rigged weren't set off by some kind
of monkey or whatever, some kind of animal. Um,
did you guys reg them a certain way that that was unlikely way the way Bubba
and, and the freshmen later would
do it and Lynn,
they would put us in an area where it would be easiest for the trackers to
follow. And so he's just based on human nature.
You're going to go through the tick part,
you're going to go where it's easier to travel and uh,
it could have been an animal, but basically it's an end
VA animal. Yeah. You know? Yeah.
The coincidence would be too much and the chances are it's just NVA.
Yeah. And then if it is a monkey as opposed to an NVA,
we're happy we'll find that out within the next couple of hours.
On the other hand, let's get ready.
Yeah. And the, so the, when there was,
when there was enemy moving in the jungle, the animals would stop making noises.
It all depends how close you are. But yes, lots hot.
That's why the most important thing in the jungle was listing. I mean 10,
10 sounds pretty extreme,
but it really gives you time to hear what's going on.
Cause a lot of time you can't see it as much.
The best sense in the jungle. And like I said, I've,
I've been in triple canopy and we've done patrolling triple canopy and you can
hit by monkeys too, right? Yeah. Well yeah we had monkeys freak us out.
But um,
okay.
That the sense just so people can understand, you can only see in,
in that thick jungle sometimes you can only see five feet. Sure.
Five or 10 feet at the most.
And so you patrol for 10 minutes and then you just stop.
Everyone is quiet and you listen to see if anyone's following you to see if
there's any other movement out there. That's what you're doing.
Sure. I mean,
and it's so thick that if I'm behind a point man or sometimes,
oh, it'd be the point man was Sao and myself, why would never see the point man,
I would just keep an eye on sal and the guy behind me would just be on my
backpack. I wouldn't, I couldn't tell you where the point man was caught.
Just follow sound. The vegetation was that thick a lot of times.
And again, I'm depending on a Vietnamese. Could they know they ended up jumbled
better than me? How come the animals would stop making noise?
Would the animal stop making noise when you would patrol?
I would assume, but once we settled down, then things would come back normal,
so when you stop moving then the sounds would escalate and if it didn't have to
10 minutes ago, the pucker factor types up to the VA a little bit more.
All right.
I immediately signaled foc who is on point to head north.
This would take us up a hill that dominated our right flank.
The climb was pretty severe, which was good and bad news.
While it made the going rough,
it also meant we were gaining some genuine high ground and high ground as the
preferred PR position. When it comes to defense,
the steepness also meant the enemy would have to work as hard as we were.
I couldn't tell how close the NVA trackers were or how many of them were headed
our way, but I knew if push came to shove,
I wanted to be looking down on them. Always take the high ground.
Always that's just military maximum and you know I or Iowa actually say you take
the moral high ground as well.
Take dialogue with the high ground is going to take you. Hey Man.
When we reached the hilltop,
just as dark clouds unleashed a torrent of rain while bubbling,
sal began put setting out a perimeter of claymores.
I can't contacted Covey and appraised him of the situation,
namely that it didn't look good and that we might be calling for an immediate
extraction before nightfall. Did you guys speak at all?
Only minimal because most of the we hand seamless. Everything has circles.
Just like usually you'd have to risk Bonnier. Yeah, but if we could,
if we just avoided it as much as we could, but something like this,
just so people understand something like this, you're on patrol.
You're not saying anything. You head up the hill, you don't say anything.
You get to perimeter, you give the perimeter signal. You don't say anything.
Everyone knows what to do. When you're in there.
You could go days out in the field without talking. Oh yeah, absolutely.
Because with the training isn't pissy.
You've got the visual with the person that you're signaling. Like in my case,
if I'm behind, fuck the point man,
I'm telling him what to do and I'll turn around and tell the guy behind me same
signals and then we go. Yup.
[inaudible]
while I was talking to
Covey Sao who had moved north to set out his claim more suddenly opened fire on
full automatic assure side we had visitors.
This was immediately confirmed when heavy AK 47 fire ripped out of the jungle
and response in less than five seconds.
The well practice Sao had fired off all 18 rounds in his car,
15 set off the claymores and reloaded his weapon while falling back to join the
rest of the team. That's the legit right there.
Sal was making things happen. He was the man.
Would you guys, you guys be trading in these immediate action drills,
mag changes, I mean everything that we do, right?
You guys drill that stuff every drill and drill and drill. If we're in camp,
we go down often and just a particularly unit beginning to June,
my first couple of months,
whenever every day Hondas arounds and when this happens,
these guys are called the enemy has come very close to you because you can at
least know that they're there. They gotta be what, 1520 maybe 30 meters away.
And in that case here,
I forget how close they weren't that far for Saudi to blow his claim or en the
car 15 and reload and do it one more time.
Okay.
Back to the book cover.
You had heard the background shots and explosions so he was not overly surprised
when I stated the obvious.
We had a prairie fire emergency in progress and we wanted out asap.
The mission was over at the fuel lines would have to wait until another day.
The focus now became saving our asses. And to this end,
every air sab would air asset within striking distance would immediately be
vectored to our target area. The odds would soon turn,
if not in our favor, very decidedly against the enemy.
Our t Idaho might not make it out alive,
but neither would the NVA.
Okay.
You guys had some serious confidence in that air power.
Yeah. That was our lifeline. I mean, um,
a major edge that we had and whenever we could use it,
we use it because, um,
it was only a matter of time before they would get more bodies there.
And we had teams that had been overrun and 67,
68 so we knew the potential for things to go really wrong.
And that was one of the things I could neutralize the manpower when they had
the, Amy has so many troops.
Did teams ever get over while they had air power? Oh, sure.
Sadly, yes. Severe. Oh yeah.
They would just keep coming as Silva Medal of honors recipients. Uh,
Fred sabotage Tasky Robert Howard s f on missions and they were directing air
power still just got overrun.
That's all part of the horror of being on the ground. The guest,
they really determined fall.
So even though you have confidence in your air power,
you know there's limitations and
yeah,
if things really go bad that air power is not going to be able to save you.
Correct. Is He? Again is time.
Whether and where are you in the jungle and the triple canopy.
If you're in triple canopy,
all you could do is maybe gun runs and you're not even sure how effective it
will be, but at least you get their attention.
[inaudible]
going back to the book, Call King Bees, call king bees beaucoup VC beaucoup VC.
It was clear Sao and I shared similar appraisal of our situation in the same
thoughts about what needed to be done. The only hitch was how to pull it off,
what with darkness approaching a storm raging and no helicopters anywhere near
us. I didn't want to add to either sow's or the team's exed. Sorry,
I didn't share my misgivings.
Instead I gave Carvey the direction and probable distance.
We'd moved from the LZ and told them I was about to throw two yellow smoke
grenades to Marco location.
I threw two hoping some of the smoke would somehow travel up through the thick
vegetation and into the clear where Covey could see it.
Covey had good and bad news. He thought he had our location,
but he doubted seriously. If he could get extraction helicopters to us before.
Nightfall not good, not good at all.
We now had confirmed enemy north and south of us and they were closing in south.
Frantically signaled Bubba to set off the south facing claymores.
When bubba hesitated for a second, I could hear Sao his code of
Co Kaka Dow VC. How do you say that? Kaka Dow Kaka Dow VC [inaudible]
Kill Dumas, which is Vietnamese for mother, mother Fockers.
As the claymores erupted,
sal pulled the pin on the fragmentation grenade and lob that into the boiling.
Dustin smoke even as even more enemy troops came up the slope with my ears
ringing from the blast. I thought I heard additional movement to the east,
but I couldn't be sure because the NVA had abandoned any pretense of stealth,
I assume verified they were coming from that flank as well and there were lots
of them. As these unseen forces maneuvered in for the kill,
the jungle took on its most terrifying and claustrophobic reality.
Not a friendly place in the very best of circumstances.
It was now about the worst place in the world to be.
Okay.
Again, that claustrophobic sense. Can you see,
can you see the sky in this triple care to be okay?
Uh, depends.
Sometimes you can see it like glimpses of it or like to be a little opening.
So he was able to see the smoke.
Sometimes you'd pop a yellow smoke which is bright and it wouldn't even be able
to get through.
Everyone was cutting loose as fast as he could in an effort to suppress the
enemies fire and drive him back.
Twatted managed to find some narrow openings in the vegetation and was shooting
rounds with his m 79 grenade launcher and suddenly the jungle went silent as if
someone had thrown a switch or hit it, hit the mute button.
The only sounds were the metallic clicks as both are t Idaho and the NVA locked
fresh magazines into their weapons. The fight was far from over.
In fact,
the party was just getting started and we were simply changing records for the
next dance with death.
The jungle again erupted with deafening roar of gunfire,
so that's sketchy. That's gotta be a horrifying feeling. Boom goes quiet.
Everyone dumps their mags.
There's that moment of silence and then that silence are you here as reload
happens.
Well, and you know too when, when that happens,
how when your adrenaline is pumping, when you're here,
your time frame has expanded. So now instead of like you just read it,
that's a quick, it is Bam, Bam, you're saying, but now I need the adrenaline.
It feels like it's slowed down. He can feel the magazine coming out.
You hear that click, click, click. Everybody else is them in. Come on,
boys come down on his first and our guys one with
all the noise.
I had to shove the radio handset damn near inside my ear to hear what Covey was
trying to tell me. The good news, bad news routine continued.
The good news was that some of the yellow smoke had finally made it its way to
where Covey could see it. But the bad news was we were nowhere near the NLZ.
He wanted to know if we could find our way back to where we had inserted
negative. I yelled as folk,
Bubba and Hap all opened up on some NVA who had managed to sneak up from the
south. There were green tracers whizzing all around me.
Covey would have to wait.
And that's another good point because in this war,
the enemy almost always had green tracers always. Okay. Yeah. For us,
they're getting me. Didn't always have great.
They'd Gret they in fact most of the time,
well a lot of times I had red cause they had no kidding. Yeah. So it was,
they learned the lesson. Yeah. So it was, you know,
just they got their ammo from all different sources and so it wasn't just this,
there wasn't just a, hey, they're green and wear red. It was mostly red,
some green occasionally, but wow. Yeah. Yeah. Um,
okay.
After helping repel the attack,
I got back on the radio to impress upon Covey,
the directness of our straits. But of course he already knew that.
So in his calm voice, which could drive a one zero to murder, he said,
we don't have a lot of time. No Shit.
The only chance we have is about a hundred meters north by northeast from your
location, there's a small hole in the roof.
We might be able to get strings down to you.
He inquired if we add much activity to our north. It depended,
I thought on what you meant by much and activity.
I reminded him that North was where the whole shooting match got started and
while the while I fought,
we had pretty much taken that group of NVA out of action.
I couldn't be sure when I finished. He said, don't worry,
I have a pair of a one e's on station and I'll have the leader make a gun run
and then give and then have his wing men follow with 500 pounders.
Before I could say Roger that the first Skyraider roared across our northern
perimeter. His 20 millimeter cannons blazing away as wood chips, dust,
and debris filled the air. The members of RTI,
Idaho did not need to be told what to do.
We kissed mother earth and pressed against her body for all we were worth in the
brief quiet that followed.
I told Bubba did per pair some explosives just in case we needed to cut down
trees at the extraction point.
I told Sal we needed to head north as that was our only chance for escape.
No one looked happy with this news, particularly not sal who had finished,
who had seen firsthand what was waiting in that direction. About this time,
the second Skyraider appeared and released it's load of 500 pound bombs.
They were so close that the concussions bounced us like jumping beans
and this is all based on the yellow smoke that you'd thrown five minutes ago or
eight minutes ago. They're looking at a massive weight.
This is another thing.
It's hard to understand or it's hard for me to understand.
I just remember I was a radio man when I was in the new guy and we were out in
the desert and we were trying to call in helicopters to come pick us up and it's
me calling them in. It's not, we isn't me.
I'm sitting there on the radio trying to call on these helicopters and I got my
air panel out and we were in the desert. This isn't triplicate,
this is the desert and these helicopters can't see me. They're, they're not far.
They're not at altitude.
They're probably 500 to 500 meters away or they'd do an apnea 30 I'll be there
looking for us there. They're kind of,
they know we're in the general area and they're looking for us and I'm sitting
there with a signal panel, like trying to get their attention.
And what you don't realize is that there's, you know,
you're seeing this helicopter, it's so obvious. I mean you,
you'd think there's no possible way that they can't see.
You'd think there's no pop where you've got a s a 16 man seal platoon out there.
I'm waving around a piece of fluoresce and orange were the only human beings in
this desert and they can't see us and now you're [inaudible].
And the reason they can't see us this, cause they're looking everywhere.
They're looking, they're looking at whatever,
however many square miles they can see into an ocean. Yeah, they're looking at,
yeah, they can see all this space. And so it takes them a while. You don't,
finally I get them to say, I think I popped this up.
I think I popped a smoke and they didn't see the smoke and then I popped another
smoke. And so that,
I can't imagine these guys are coming in hot dropping bombs based on where the,
not even him,
but where the Covey saw smoke five minutes ago.
Yeah.
We may have popped into a smoke in here somewhere and also I know that I had
talked to Cubby Kay,
here's our smoke north of us and he knew they had,
we had a lot of Actelion north and south and he forgot about maybe what we were
getting from the east button if we're talking about trying to get to the north.
That's why he came across the northern. So he knew basically where we weren't.
He came in and of course the 500 pounds,
we're able to get through the jungle and impact on the ground.
I had those things. Rocked you guys. Oh yeah.
Uh, it's one of those happy pains. Ugh.
Good Times. I guess. Tilt. Alright.
With the a one e activity to occupy us,
we had momentarily taken our attention away from our southern flank and now a
wave of NVA hit us from that direction.
Everyone responded with automatic fire and Bubba and I lobs some grenades down
the slope.
I informed Covey of the attack and told him that when I gave the word and the
team moved to the north, I wanted more a one. He runs to ourself.
In my heart of hearts, I also wanted more runs to the north,
but we didn't have time for that. We had to get out while the getting was good,
the next NVA wave could be the one to overrun us.
Okay.
As bubba finished preparing explosives happened,
I continued rolling grenades downhill toward the enemy.
Sal and folk covered Twan with car 15 fire.
As he set up a or facing south and covered it with leaves,
a little parting gift for our friends.
The race was on.
I gave Covey the word and behind us the a one at the a one ease began bombing
the shit out of whoever was back there. Folk angled back to the north.
We passed the, we pass bodies of dead NVA soldiers,
but we didn't have time to stop and search them for papers or anything of an
intelligence value. We had only one thought in mind get out.
It was something of a miracle that Farkin sal actually located the spot Covey
had found for us when we finally looked up toward the hole itself. However,
it appeared a long, long ways away. It was at least a hundred feet or more.
And the green tunnel leading to it was narrow and dangerous.
As we were approaching,
I'd seen the tops of trees being whipped around by the gusting wind and knew
this would complicate matters even more. This was not going to be an easy exit.
So you guys are moving to this thing,
you're looking up at the tree tops and you see there's like a heavy wind cause
it's story that's just weather, wind like it's wet, it's windy out.
And we had weather forecasts and it might be some problems with the weather.
And so here we are as dark and I'm, I didn't tell the guises. I mean, yeah,
I knew that seeing those trees like that. This is, yeah,
and it was getting late. Dark. I needed your Knox.
Yeah, you did wish you could add them bro.
They want to totally change this whole scenario because the helicopter,
because the aircraft too sure. Cause the aircraft would be, oh yeah, we got you.
Yeah we got you locked and we'll just wait. You guys can just, you know,
pitch a tent. Uh,
and the NVA, this still, you know, the,
the big motto of the insurgence, right,
is that they only fight when they want to and they don't have to fight if they
don't need to.
And you don't imagine troops that don't have to fight,
just keep coming after you just keep your, you're laying waste to them,
but they keep coming.
That must've be the value of capturing you all cross border would be so high
that they just must have had serious intent to try and capture.
Well, yeah. And then then too, you know,
you had that propaganda Dave been fed for all those years.
They really believed it. They really believed that like the French,
we were there to occupy where we were just, there was combat in communism,
but then they never heard any of that stuff and he were dedicated.
That's absolutely, Yes sir.
Back to the book. The NVA had not given up. Its troops were hot on our tail,
even though we had heard Twan claymore go off and had listened to the
[inaudible] work them over, you had to hand it to the NVA soldiers.
They were very tough and determined.
I again contacted Covey and asked for some,
asked for some tactical air command, air support to our,
and in a matter of minutes, bombs were falling and canons were blasting away.
Yeah,
I'm sure I was impressed with the service as the NVA were surprised by how
quickly the ordinance had been delivered.
They were learning a lesson the hard way.
If a recon team wasn't wiped out in the first few minutes of the fight,
the NVA would pay dearly for the mistake.
Okay.
But more than one NVA unit had experienced this firsthand.
So that's kind of a creek, a critical few minutes, as long as it,
how long did it take for Eric to get on station? Usually
well dependent, every, every worse from several hours to, in this case, uh,
we were fortunate to make contact really early on with Covey. Hoot,
fortunately had a ones that were within a few minutes away.
So there was some luck involved very much.
I mean we saw them had that kind of response and layoffs.
Did you ever preplan to have coverage at certain times
it would be a special mission. Yeah, like the ones we put in, the uh,
sensors you put 'em in and you know,
you're going to be in the ground for two or three hours. He booked a times,
had the assets set, so we have to go,
or something happens in between bing you can come in. But most of them
where these were these aircraft necessarily briefed on the mission itself.
So do they were they know coming in, hey,
this is the EO that they're working or these guys just come in there, right.
They were just random pilots, ob, both, they has Pacific,
a one units in the air force, uh,
in that timeframe that were specifically there for SOG,
missions and Sar,
say search and rescue up north for any down pilots. So,
um,
they were very much attuned to our people working with Kontomble and with us up
north. Um,
so they knew everything was in a prairie fire. AAO.
Sometimes when you,
like when we're in echo for our first contact was with a fighter jet,
the heard the earth 10 beeper and responded to that.
So, and other missions, uh, another aircraft would hear it and um,
they would, if they had an ordinance then we had the, you know, get to Miri,
get them located to find us and,
and bring in the ordinance while he put the call out to get the Covey or the
Hillsborough or Moonbeam left the note.
He had a tactical emergency going on here.
And you're doing all that on the radio while you're still fighting.
Okay.
Yeah. We had had to spend a few rounds or lighten the load.
All right.
Bubba Sao and foc had been busy placing explosive charges on trees while Hap
Antwan set out claymores facing south. I couldn't help but shake my head.
Okay.
In wonder at Hap in a dark jungle with knight approaching,
he still had his ever present sunglasses.
We booed the charges around the trees and they were cut clean.
But the dense jungle refuse to let them fall.
We had not succeeded in making the hole any bigger.
So we just have to hope the rescue ships could manage to drop the ropes down to
us and then pray the ropes were long enough.
So you're trying to make that hole in the jungle a little bit bigger.
Like what diameter is this hole that you're looking at? Oh,
this is like 10 meters. Is it? Not that. Yeah, that's a good question.
Maybe 20, 30 meters. Okay. There's trees in it. Yeah, no,
it's at least it's a little bit more open as opposed to just chapel canopy
enclosed where you're just completely, we could see skylight,
you can literally see the sky, but, and then you try and blow some of the trees,
but they don't even fall down because there's too much junk to mines.
There are too many retreats. Yes, exactly. It doesn't even help. Didn't help.
Good Times. Add to the frustration.
Uh, we tried to blow up some palm trees, or actually it was Lafe laughs, uh,
platoon tried to blow up some palm trees that were obstructing their view,
you know, Overwatch position. Right.
And they blew up.
They said they sit so many charges on these palm trees. It was embarrassing.
I launched, I got rotten. No, they weren't. They didn't budge. No,
I got embarrassed. I've, I'm sitting there telling the battalion commander,
he's saying what I'm saying, hey, there's sir,
there's going to be another controlled debt and boom,
and then there's going to be another control debt and then boom,
and then so there's going to be another controlled bet and then boom. He said,
what are they doing? I said, you tried to get rid of some bomb trees.
Don't worry about it. You know what sir?
We're just going to leave those palm trees. He had a score.
Right now there's palm trees. Three seals. Zero. Yeah, that's what happened.
Oh No. Those palm trees are hard. Resilient. Thick.
Alright. Back to the book with the helicopters on their final approach.
I threw out another smoker need to mark our location and the rest of the team
began firing at the end VA, who had again pressed in on us,
we could barely make out, make out their shadows,
but they were definitely out there as evidenced by the green tracer rounds
flying towards us. Covey hadn't been able to see my smoke,
so he asked for a pen flair. When I tried to fire it up through the trees,
it struck a limb and bounced back being desperate.
I told Covey I was going to shoot three tracer rounds,
red tracer rounds up through the hole and before he could scream, no,
I had pulled the trigger on my car.
15 I immediately realized what a dangerous move it was as I saw him pass
overhead in case there was any doubt in my mind.
Covey took the time to let me know in no uncertain terms how stupid I was.
I believe the expressions dumb asked and shit for brains came into play
wildly. So you're in this situation,
you still took the time to call you shit for brains.
You know you're about to die priories. Oh Man.
Yeah. And you know, I was thinking I, I'd never fought in Afghanistan.
I Dunno what they had and if they saw a lot of more green tracers over there off
to ask them. I'm a buddies and never really thought about that. Um,
so that's uh, that was that just like the normal little pencil flair,
the little trigger thing. You crank around like a 22 round that fires up.
It's a tracer. Yes. You got it. It didn't penetrate through.
So you decide you're just going to fire some car rounds but fuck my tracers.
But they saw them, right? They did. Yeah. So hey one for till
just before the rescue choppers attempted to hover and drop the ropes,
I told Covey I wanted the gunships that accompanied them to work over the area
around us, particular to the south.
I wanted the NVA to be either dead wounded or with their heads buried in the
ground. When we tried to make our escape the muskets,
the men from the 176th assault helicopter company immediately went to work with
their 2.75 inch rockets and they're Gatling like mini guns,
multi barreled weapons that could pump 6,000 rounds of seven six two a minute.
As the last rocket hit and exploded behind us,
the first hundred first airborne division slick appeared over the hole and the
jungle roof and dropped sandbags with ropes attached to them.
The helicopter was so high up,
it looked like a toy and even its powerful rotor wash couldn't reach us.
I could tell he wasn't being buffeted by the wind,
but he'd somehow managed to hold steady over the opening.
One of the sandbags attached to the rope had a strobe light attached to it and
we watched it bounce off the limbs as it fell toward us.
You guys, I guess they hadn't invented the jungle penetrator yet.
You know what it has, but not on us. Okay.
They had them on the HH threes and that's just the mean giants. Yeah.
For those of you that don't know, it's like a big metal,
uh Yap jungle penetrators, a big metal kind of spear,
almost spirit and it was still cabled as hook to a crane and it just drops down
and that weight and it's well shaped as opposed to just a random sandbag.
It bouncing and so this thing was hot.
This thing must've been like 150 feet up. Yeah,
they had the longest ropes in there. A surprise even got down to us
back to the book while we kept an eye on the ropes descending through the trees.
The NVA mounted a desperate last charge towards us.
Twan and Hep triggered their cake claymores and the rest of us opened up with
all we had. Somehow in the midst of all the tumultuous activity,
the four [inaudible] had managed to rig themselves a Swiss seat using the six
foot long pieces of rope we carried just for that purpose.
Bubba nine now tried to do the same,
but it wasn't easy to wrap a rope around my waist,
pass it between my legs and then finish tying it off on the right hip while
under fire.
But we managed to do it while the Indians held off the enemy and began to hook
up for the lift out.
You guys ever think about using some kind of pre rigged like sitting or
something?
They, they were developing those as time they upgraded.
They had like the McGuire rig,
which is just basically a thick material that you could sit in and hook in.
And then later came out with the rigs. Um, I can't think of now, but it was a,
uh, an outfit where you had your harness built in sandy web gear with a harness.
So when, when it came down,
you just hooked link in Click and you're ready to go.
I'd be thinking about that a lot when I, when I found this,
you try to tie us to a seat. Oh yeah.
That's awesome.
We were getting low on ammunition grenades and claymores.
If we didn't make it out, it was going to be a very long night. In fact,
I wasn't sure we,
I wasn't sure if we could survive the night no matter what kind of air support
managed to reach us. It was now or never salad,
foc located three of the four ropes and it attached themselves to one of them
using snap links.
When I asked Covey if the chopper could lift us all out at once, he replied,
no way. It's going to take two lifts.
No way is exactly what I thought in return.
There was no way we had enough time for two attempts.
There was no way I was going to split the team either.
All six of us were going out together on four ropes or we were going to die
together trying call it comradery or fear,
but I was not going to leave anyone,
myself included on the ground for a minute longer than necessary.
I had heard all the horror stories I needed to about what could result in and I
didn't want to be the subject of some gruesome tail around the bar at Fob one.
I suddenly had a bright idea and asked Bubba if he still had the claim worn with
a white phosphorus grenade tape to its front when he nodded yes,
I told him to strap it as high as he could,
as high as he could reach on a nearby tree facing south. He gave me his best.
Are you out of your fucking mind? Look,
because he knew at that proximity the back blast would kill us all when we set
it off. So he hesitated and I had to order him to do it.
Once he finished the remaining two little people paired up and hooked themselves
on to into one of the ropes while Bubba and I each took one of the remaining
two,
I wanted to balance out the weight distribution by having me on one side of the
helicopter and bub on the other,
but it was impossible to tell for sure which ropes went where.
So I took a wild guess and hope for the best,
best using the barrel of my m 79 to shield the flash from the NBA.
I used a strobe light to signal the chopper to begin to lift to begin lifting us
out.
Yeah.
Did the chopper have enough power? Would we be dragged through the trees?
Would the NVA managed to shoot one or all of us out of our saddles?
We were about to find out as the ropes became taught,
fire gunfire erupted from the West Sao fuck and I returned fire butter bodies
blocked the other's line of sight,
so they watched in frustration because my rope was longer than the other three.
I was the last to leave the ground.
This also gave me the additional seconds I needed to reload my empty car.
15 twice. Things were happening very fast,
almost too fast, and my bright idea demanded perfect timing. As we started up,
bubba reached out and ignited the delay flu's on the the,
the delay fuse on the last claymore,
the one he'd fastened to the tree with my feet dangling in the air,
I fired around from my m 79 still gaining altitude.
I then pulled the pins on two hand grenades and tossed him down onto the ground
at about the same time.
The claim more went off the back blast blue wonder us,
but we could still feel its power and heat.
The phosphorus was like a giant flash bulb going off in that frozen instant of
illumination, I could finally see the faces of my enemy.
They were hurting but still advancing with its engine screaming.
The Huey somehow came up with the power it needed.
It was agonizingly slow going and we had to push our way through some branches,
but we were not being dragged through them. We were being lifted straight up.
The NVA continued to fire at us and I had the unsettling impression that tracer
rounds were passing between my legs and a sensation that will give any man pause
for thought.
The team fired back on full automatic and we threw the last of our grenades back
to fiercely demented and determined beasts.
The NVA and our t Idaho remain locked in battle to the bitter end.
Okay.
As we find the cleared the trees,
I immediately called Covey and confessed our little deception. The team is out,
the whole team is out. I screamed into the handset. We came out together,
do not send in a second helicopter. I repeat. No second chopper.
Okay.
The muskets rolled in and pull Vera's the ground.
We had just left the a one were right behind them and as the muffled explosion
and light flashes reached me,
I found myself feeling a little sorry for the NVA troops down there.
They were Valeant and dedicated soldiers. They would have,
they would have been a credit, a credit to any army.
Those left alive would no doubt, have some stories to tell,
but I doubted they would ever admit that a six man team had held them at bay for
so long and then escaped their most determined to efforts to wipe them out.
As for our Idaho, we were simply happy to be alive.
Not something I would have bet on a short while earlier.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. And we were just,
I mean we were lucky too because of the, it was called,
you were more lucky than that.
I mean we used up a whole lot of luck on that one. But you know, it was a,
we were lucky because we were still relatively high and not like the big peaks
and deeper into Lagos and so the helicopter was able to pull us out if that had
been in the middle of the day in with jungle heat and heat of the day.
He never would've been able to if six of us out.
But we weighed all that and I did list a cubby just rolled the dice because it
was so dark or her at that point. So,
oh yeah. The recon guides smart on us one more time.
So when you, when you, once you got pulled out,
would they just look for a clearing somewhere to set down,
get you guys in the helicopter for real? No, that's the part that's put,
they just froze your balls off
because with the Swiss seed, you know how it is with the rope. You just,
everything goes numb. Yeah. And so because it was dark particularly,
they want to make sure that he,
wherever he pours down is going to be somewhere in south Vietnam.
So we were in the air. I just forget how long and I finally sat us down.
But you can't walk. You just, you lie to like a cripple for a few minutes,
clip on clip. He can't flip.
So, so they, so they didn't really care about your comfort?
No. And we, and we didn't complain too much, but he's a, he, you go,
you're all sweaty and you how it is when it five,
five minutes later you're at 5,000 feet, which is cold.
People forget how cold it is at 5,000 feet.
Yeah. You're freezing. Yeah.
Especially cause you're soaking wet and you're going 80 miles an hour,
80 mile an hour wind. Yeah. All that too.
Yeah. This is just, I mean it's just crazy.
It's absolutely crazy.
And this was just over and over again now. Um,
you know,
I spent a lot of time on the books on the last couple podcasts I wanted to,
I wanted to kind of just ask you a couple of questions,
get your thoughts on some stuff. Um, and I also,
and I know we might have to come back again, but I've got saw chronicles here,
I read that outstanding book, you know, and this is [inaudible] chronicles, uh,
real quick talks about a big operation that, uh,
took place that you weren't on,
but you got really good descriptions and talk to people operation tailwind.
That's another one where helicopters are getting shot down.
I mean it's completely, completely insane.
Yeah. And it is and no,
no ordinary hilic these are the CS 50 threes Delta models the biggest a marine
corps had. And he took out two of those. I left one really banged up. Yeah.
And when they inserted, they still, they had three wis on their assertion,
but they had to get in for that to take the pressure off of the CIA operation.
That was
their mission. September, 1970. Yeah, that's, so that's operation tailwind,
operation tailwind in that that book saw chronicles volume one and I hope
there's going to be about 30 more volumes of solid work on it.
The model that Anne and I came up with is that we're going to write till we die.
I like it because there's so many songs,
stories they have never been told because we couldn't tell.
And so many of our guys, I mean even when I, a fellow recon guy talked to him,
it's like pulling information out.
I'm sure you've run into that with your people that they're not,
they're not inclined to talk. Well, yeah. And you know, modest.
That's an interesting thing cause people to, not the wannabes at the bar,
you know, I'm a green baret or Omar seal and most of the guys, when you know,
people say, well you should have more guys from t your bruiser on there.
You have to have more guys,
more seals on the seals that I know that I would want to have on a lot of them.
They're still in or they don't want to come on that. They won't say a word.
Yeah. They're like, Hey, no, I'm good. You know,
and then obviously I got a lot of my friends that do come on and it's great when
they come on. But yeah, a lot of guys are still doing it, you know,
and so, hey, that's the way it is.
I want once those guys retire and I do have some friends that are retiring soon
and they're becoming on, so that's pretty awesome. Oh yeah. But um, yeah,
so the sod chronicles, uh, you, you've, like I said,
hopefully there's 30 volumes of that right now. There's just one.
We're going to try to turn across the fence and on the ground into audio books.
That's awesome. That's our project right now.
And then as soon as we're done with that, to commence a, with volume two
and Wa, we got a couple of stories there. Uh,
well the one that we talked about and on the ground,
the August 23rd attack, we've had a lot more research.
We had this Gal who's, uh,
as she was in emi and she has pulled out more information as we're going to pull
the whole thing together for the,
hopefully the most detailed store in a night because it was such a tragic yet
heroic night for the people that were there on the ground at night.
And Larry Tremble up on a marble mountain here. So we have that.
A couple of the stories, many other stories, but there's the other one.
One of our guys went in for a bright light and they got shot out an a,
a, a for crashed as it was crashing.
It hit three separate hilltops come to the restaurant and third one,
they got to the second hill and got shot out.
He went back 25 years later, he became a doctor on his own money,
spent $70,000 to go back to Cambodia to try to find that forage.
Just nod as conscience. They got in,
got to the site and were run off by bandits.
He meant back now it'd be two years ago with DPA and DPA was working on the
second hill where the jet was on the Third Hill.
So he's able to go in to give them direct, uh,
citing as to where to dig.
So they're still working and he was on the ground digging things out with these
guys that's going to be in that book.
Yeah. So check out that book too. Saw Chronicles, um,
you're training. How ready
do you think you were when you got to Vietnam? How ready for you for
what you were about to encounter? Well,
a lot better than the guys that went through just basic training and advanced
infantry training and I'm sure that commenced on units had in country training.
Our in country training was, was good. He worked, we, you know,
we practice calling in spooky, worked with the helicopters,
told about the dangerous and working with the little people,
the history as well as some of the do's and don'ts about working with south
Vietnamese. And I thought that was good.
But then two distal eight camp duty, which is,
I think all of that was geared for the eight camps.
SOG was just in another level and that's why we always talked.
So people like Patois and spider parks, John McGovern, um,
Dick Gross theoret to senior east sevens are aesics is in camp,
all of whom had run at night. US Green guys would talk to them,
particularly after mission. And then we talked to each other. You know,
John Walton came back from a target and uh, where, uh,
Tom Cunningham's leg was blown off,
one of those little people that got shot four times and Captain Tin who saved us
in October, pulled them out in August and we talked right away that night.
Well, what'd you learn? And it always be this back and forth to try to,
uh,
get any sense of what happened with anything you could do to give us anything
for another edge on, in a field. And meanwhile, we're getting the Intel reports.
We knew Bella teens had been wiped out and the Intel reports about the sappers.
So y'all bounced it out. And just key thing was comma.
So in answer to your question, SOG was so different.
A lot of with innovative to things we were doing there with the strings.
That was all things that you use today really advanced in no, no fast ropes.
That was another dimension of when the war,
so we're working at firepower, working with the air assets,
um, and new weapons.
But it was all I could experiment on things to learn as you go.
Try to take what's best and like Lynn black blow yourself up in a an ambush just
for good luck to make sure it really works.
Did you, when you were calling for fire, so I don't know if you know this,
but now it's like a school you go to, you,
you go to a joint tactical air controller school and that's sort of your
specialty is calling for fire calling and bombs,
but you just, you trained in country to learn how to do it.
Yes. And again we talk to,
that's where we talked to spider and Pat walking specifically.
And so that was it. That was more important than act actually going out,
popping smoke and having a gun run. It was learning how to do it the right way.
Now you're in a box and you never have a gun run, go cross.
You could be in front, you know,
you're front to left southeast and you'd direct it that way.
In the how many inches, I mean how many feet or yards from your perimeter,
how many meters.
And that applied when we got to the field because once we were up at Fubu by,
we didn't practice airstrikes once we were on the ground, we did it.
But it did it with confidence thanks to spider walk-ins and John McGovern
particularly, they sat with our, the green guys at night and made us, you know,
understand that.
And we had a couple of cases where people made mistakes and teams got hit and
lost people. They had a, they were bringing in some people, we are,
our body count was so low that they were bringing in people from other units and
they would come in cocky and uh, when,
once they got on the ground they would just maybe a little too cocky and hadn't
listened to the lessons and some of the teams would let other people carry their
rest. Why character radio. And we have one team,
young guy came in and called the airstrike cornerstone team.
They came with a gun room right across the teams, Ron. And it's like that,
you know. So yeah,
I, I that does not surprise me at all. I mean,
when I'm listening to or reading your books,
the fact that you guys were doing that,
you could obviously had a massive amount of skill to not have that happen.
Because like I said, these guys are looking at a jungle canopy.
They're looking at some random bit of smoke that came out and yet you're
directing fire based on that. It's, it's, it's awesome.
But I could see where somebody could easily, you know,
make a mistake and you know, you give the wrong direction. You, you know,
you look at your compass suspending the wrong way, you know, it's crew,
close your weapon, you've got your cardinal directions.
I mean there's so many things that could go wrong that and yet,
and yet you're just doing, I mean there's times we're out there doing,
going runs for, for 12 hours, straight, long,
long time. And in like your case where you had the, um,
the unit that you wanted to tack the building and you challenged that three
times in the last time you called it out because it was another unit,
another seal team.
Well we had that common sense thing on the ground to where we would direct it,
but if there was something that wasn't quite right,
you put everything on hold until you got it right.
Yeah. That's,
it's weird cause Leif and I wrote extreme ownership and we didn't really
coordinate stories that we were talking about.
And yet there's multiple stories in there about either blue on blues or
potential blue and blues.
Cause man in a city like that with all these different different units running
around all on different radio frequencies and a bunch of enemy Musha Dean
fighters running around in there too. It blue on blue was a very real thing.
And there would be probably the one case of blue on blue a day that would happen
and maybe one a week that would get reported, you know, but just,
and I'm not talking where somebody gets shot but, but like, you know,
just all of a sudden you're taking rounds and you're like,
where are those coming from?
Oh that's another unit down there and maybe they're four and four and a one
opening up on the, exactly. Exactly. So that it would happen all the time.
Um, and that's one thing that was nice about, well for you it was not nice,
but it's less complicated.
You're the only friendly guys out there that won't you,
there was no friendly fire half than you guys. This US versus them. Yeah,
it's all them. Uh,
when you got mission taskings, where'd they come from? Where they,
where they coming from up above. Where you guys developing targets yourself?
Where did that, how did that work?
Yes, we're happy mix of both. Um,
do the chain of command for SOG went to [inaudible] headquarters right to their
White House. They had somebody from dod that was there, some, I don't know,
some general somebody, but that was their mission was to keep an eye on saw.
So they would send missions from near that would come to headquarters to each
have will be, and then our immediate action reports,
and I'll go back after actually report to go back through the chain of command.
So they knew what was going on at the White House.
There's somebody at the warehouse, that's where we were told.
And on occasions if we had a target that we wanted to do,
B 52 strike that, we'd go back through the chain of command and then
approval on it. But the, the, from what the public knew,
the public knew we were bombing none. He didn't know anything about the answer.
Cambodia then they didn't even know we were bombing Laos and Cambodia, correct?
Nothing. There are no reporters in there.
There's no communist news network back then. Um, so,
and the communists would not talk about it because they had agreed to the
agreement of not having their people, their cadeau. He said, Hey Leon, I can't,
but they're neutral. We respect them. Lion Dogs. And we said the same thing,
but ours,
we just went in with our recon teens as opposed to them just going down and
enslaving all the people to work there, work with us, help us open the roads.
And you know, if we saw indigenous people, we were not open fire on it. I mean,
it's like you're not going to go out to the local people don't any better just
caught in the middle. Um, but the NBA,
they, they, they tell you, work with us so you die. Yeah.
Well, you, you know, in one of the books you're talking about how the,
the NVA treated the [inaudible] people,
they're so horribly that the indulge troops that you worked with like hated the
NVA. Oh, they hated them.
These NVA had raped their women and beat their wives and just done horrible
things to them after they were there for, they were there to fight.
Yup. And they, they cut nobody any slack.
I mean America today particularly are snowflakes.
Don't know what the soldiers of calmness from we're really like in the field and
just nasty people. And um,
that's what we were fighting and they were dead.
They were really dedicated and their,
their sense of purpose because there have been so thoroughly indoctrinated and
they really believe what they're doing even though they're working off a
propaganda. Yeah.
When you, so the, so you would come up with some of the missions,
some of the missions would come down to you. Majority came,
majority of came down to you.
You know, they would have sometimes I think there would be,
we got to get a team on the ground. That's why we were going in primary.
Secondary all gets shot out, eat lunch,
go back and try again because they just wanted to get somebody on the ground and
that would just be your sr automatic area reconnaissance.
And that's because they had something they wanted to see their,
some something like that sometimes harassed me.
People would just want to get a team on the ground so they can be pour to
headquarters at night. We have one or two teams on the ground.
Where do you mean that they're just wanting to, hey, look what we're doing.
Yeah.
Now I'll shortly guys or an s three would deny that and emphatically,
but it felt like that. Yeah. You came back and said,
here's the new target and they'll pick an LC for you while you're flying back to
the next target. Did you ever, what if you,
what if there was a mission that you looked at and you said, hey, this is dumb.
This doesn't make sense.
What does only one that I declined around about Christmas time of 68 I just had
a feeling and a team went in and I was word,
but they were on the ground for five days and it was a dry hole and they came
out without any shots fired or anything,
so that's the only time I officially turn something down.
Maybe that's why he had a bad feeling and tell if you knew nothing was going to
happen. It wasn't your kind of target. I don't want a boring target.
Uh, so if so, how did that go when you, when you said no, what'd you say?
Hey look, my guys need rest. Sorry. Yeah. Not this time.
We had the right to say no, no,
it was frowned on. Yeah. But you know, they had,
at that time we had a couple of new teams in camp and Rodney had came in and he
was just good one zero. So he went out, he came back, said, hey, you know,
that target was pretty cool. We uh, slept a lot. Dry Hole, dry hole was really,
so I had all these feelings man, and I was hyperventilate.
Interiorly I figured we're gonna run into hoochie men is in, you know,
a couple of divisions. Again for good luck.
I hadn't seen the division in a month. Now it's like, okay,
but no, see and that kind of show me how your mental state of mind too.
Cause I was really, that's why I believed that.
And the system was such that you could turn it down and we took it from there.
Where you say that's where you believed you,
you believed that it was a bad target.
I just felt we had been so lucky and going through the Christmas,
thanksgiving and everything else that are,
I just fell our number's going to build,
you know how [inaudible] and I just said this could be the target.
I said m a target and those were particularly, there were the, uh,
the ones who are all along the DMZ river, uh,
west of Vietnam that went deeper into Laos and they were nasty.
We lost several teams up there. I figured this could be our turn.
So buzz wrong.
Uh Huh. Now did you ever get that feeling again?
Not, not, not in a strong enough to act on it.
And I mean the carrot in the back of my tiny mind, he was like,
that's the last time you thought you were going to die. You didn't.
I had some guys that thought they were going to die every time we left the wire.
You know what I mean? God bless him. But he's, no man, this could,
I could be the night man. No, I'm going to feel good about this one.
And they'd always get their gear on.
But I'd say I always looked at it as a good sign. If certain people were scared,
if they wouldn't, wouldn't have been scared.
I would have been nervous cause they were so scared all the time. I think man,
this must be really stressful for him.
Yeah. I never wrote the letter like dear mom and dad, I'm dead now.
If you read this letter, I'm dead. Yeah. Um, I know,
I just felt and hope that we somehow get through it and uh,
and you're right about the scare thing. You, you want that emotional edge.
A little fear can go along. It's a great motivator. But I wouldn't,
I wouldn't go out with the guy if somebody was saying, hey man, I'm not afraid.
I'm afraid of you. Do you go somebody else?
I also used to get the feeling that if you were scared like that,
if you were, if you were scared and you were going to be hesitant,
that was going to be bad. Sure. Like I,
I was more worried about guys that were like hesitant or I felt like if they
were hesitant on the battlefield that would work out bad for them.
The guys that I always felt like, okay, if someone's aggressive, not, not,
not unafraid and suicidal like that, but just, hey, oh yeah,
I'm going to go do, I'm going to, we're going to go kick ass right now.
I was fault. That was the attitude to have was to be aggressive was to be like,
okay, yeah, we're, oh you want, you got an op for us, cool, we'll go do it now.
We turned down ops too. There was ops where we looked at and said, man,
this is not good and this is a massive amount of risk.
I mean there was areas where there was areas where
there were take IED strikes on vehicles and like, you know,
and went in a big Id hits a home v everyone dies or oh yeah,
three out of five people die or something like that. I mean it's,
it's very catastrophic and there was one target. They were looking at it for us.
They asked us to do and the, there was like one road going in,
they'd had multiple odd big IED strikes and then they wanted us to,
they were asking if we could take out mortar.
He was either a mortar team or an IUD in place or we are looking at it and where
the mortars had been launched from, we're all over the place. So it was just,
it was one of the, one of the types of missions where we looked at it and said,
hey,
there's got to be a better way to do this because us going up there is not going
to be worth it because a lot of your missions were point missions. Right.
What do you mean by that? They give you a target,
get to the point and wipe it out. Uh,
I would say my first deployment it was go capture, kill bad guys.
That was my first deployment to Iraq.
We were in Baghdad where that's mostly what we're doing in the middle of the
night. We'd find out where a bad guy was, we'd go get them.
And that's what my second deployment in Ramadi,
mostly what guys were doing was Overwatch sniper,
Overwatch positions set up in buildings so that when the bad guys would either
maneuver on friendly forces or they'd be out doing what they shouldn't be doing,
right, the guys would take them out. So that's, that's pretty much the end.
There's all kinds of crap in between that. Everything from, you know,
everything from doing just reconnaissance of areas to counter mortar types that
you just, you know, a lot of other, a lot of other things would happen.
But primarily it was direct action missions going out to take out a target or
these sniper Overwatch types. But you know, we'd be doing big clearances too.
Big conventional clearances. You know, we had our, we called them John Ds,
which is John d means it means soldier in, in Arabic. Right.
And, and so we call them John Ds. That's what they called themselves. John Ds.
But so we had Joan Dee's like, you guys had little people like [inaudible].
We had Indian forces, they were Joan Ds.
And so we would do very conventional missions with the jumbies of them and us,
you know,
we'd be overseeing them as they cleared big sections of the city and we'd be
working in conjunction with the army. So yeah,
we did a little bit of everything, but um,
that brings us back to our side of it where you can give yourself a mental
delusion,
which is our mission is to go look an area recon.
So theoretically you're going to get inserted quietly and go about your job and
that's different from you what your point missions,
a whole different field wine. So [inaudible] okay.
We're hoping to get into our mission to come back and report or find a fuel
line, blow it up or it gets appeal.
Dubby get the wiretaps give them Intel where you're going out and doing your IUD
pickups in and mortars. That's totally different.
So at least in my mind,
I think that's part of my self comfort factor that we're going to get inserted
in carbon. Nice quiet mission for five or six days. Take some pictures.
That sounds great. And come on back. It's really cool. Yeah,
we're behind enemy lines.
What percentage of operations would you guys get contacted on? Oh,
we left always left under fire. The only question was how much never had,
well one,
they won a where we got you opened up our discussion tonight there where we got
pulled out as no fire there because they came in and got,
we had a great Ron and we were going to get some pow but they pulled us out
right away. So there's no gun fire in that mission. But other than that,
every time we left under gunfire is the only question how much.
So Tyler is like the whole jungle was wide enough,
sometimes only be two or 300 and yet you still fooled yourself into thinking,
Hey, this recon is going to be different. But yeah,
so I guess my point was I looked at it and I still look at it.
If you are nervous about getting hurt,
if you're nervous about something going wrong,
to me that's when something goes wrong. When you're nervous about it. Now,
I'm not saying you should be arrogant about it and think, oh,
we're going to get away with whatever. But I'm saying like,
when you're doing this, even when you're doing like a sport, you know,
even when you're doing some physical activity, if you,
if you're afraid you might get injured. To me, that's when you get injured.
It's when the, when you're, when you're afraid, I think fear can hurt you.
And that being said, the other side of the coin is if you have no fear,
well then you're definitely, you're definitely at risk. He who has a taste lost.
There you go.
So there's a dichotomy there that's got to get balanced between and that's where
we're so lucky we have to sell,
did a great job of vetting are our indigenous troops and to go from spider parks
to Wilkin to Bubba and then back to Lynn black.
And then when I left the team was in Lynn's hands and I came back,
lends the one zero, what more could you ask for? So that was just the, you know,
very fortunate. What was your, uh, your mission planning like?
So you guys get a tasking. How long does it, how long did you guys plan for?
Uh, for, it's just an area of mission, uh, area. We constant, very little,
put the wire tabs opposite. We did ours now as a training on that.
And then as time went on, you know,
first it was just sal who could do it and then south trained have and fuck to
guys who are strong to do it all. And um,
as well it'd be aspect of it.
And then we cross trained each other and we even had,
so that hap would begin to teach a couple of young guys,
basic English. So if any of us got killed,
Hep could take over the radio or the ditch could takeover.
So a couple of guys like chow and hung as it went. Ha Honk came on a team,
they picked up English pretty quick.
So he worked with him and we practice calling,
working on the radios to problems with the batteries and things like that.
So we cross trained everything back and forth.
And the wire tap was one particular one where we had several guys on a team
trained up to do it all. Everything for knowing about the batteries,
watching it, keeping a battery indicator to get an uh,
put the wire up the tree or a telephone pole.
And when you came down and you covered it with mud, that was from that area.
So it would look like was part of that area and try to cover the wire.
But as far as the actual mission planning of,
okay, here's where we're going in tonight,
that didn't take you much because you were running repetitive type missions,
right?
It's a high degree of similarity. The most important thing was the training.
So when you may contact, you could take care of yourself and how to react,
try to continue to mission. But these were like [inaudible].
So once you have been seen or compromised, the mission's compromised.
Would you would be flying in.
What was your degree of certainty on where you were inserted?
Oh, we knew very clear where we're gone.
So like in a case we would talk to Covey,
we'd send a three LZs down to Saigon and Kabi would go pick a site and then he
would tell me on a radio kid, this is where we're gone. And you would be,
would you be looking at your map as you started? And he knew what,
what the frame was.
Who would be in within that map that we are that second map that we a car,
remember when we first,
you know, w w as a radio man, believe it or not, when gps first came out,
the radium and kind of got saddled with the gps because it was a piece of
electronic equipment, right?
And then no one else could work with electronic or women. So,
so I would be usually a lot of times be carrying the GPS as opposed to the
appointment. And the point man, you know,
we're still using map encompasses the early nineties but the GPS wouldn't always
work well in a helicopter.
And so sometimes they took me, you know,
this was some training operations where I learned, oh,
so well I'm not where I think I am.
And you get out and that gps finally finds itself and you realize you're three
clicks away from where you're supposed to be or whatever, and it's bad.
And that's why we'd go, I went back to, hey, when I'm in a helicopter,
I'm on a map. So that way when my boss looks at me and says, Hey,
we were where we were supposed to be. You either yes or no,
like don't get out of the bird or okay, we're good. But, but that,
so I was thinking about that for you guys.
You'd be doing the same thing as you approach to, okay, Yup.
There's that train feature. There's this other train feature. Cool. Where we're,
where we're supposed to be.
Yeah.
And then Laos also want to know where the water was because some the targets,
they had more, more streams of things. So we, we carry less water.
I have lily just carry one canteen with the purification pills so that if we're
in for it several days, like with echo four, but ended the first day a,
we had gone through some water and took,
we all took a turn going to his little stream, put the purification pills in,
hit the water and let us sit for a couple hours before we drank it.
Did you get acclimated where you needed less water? Oh yeah, absolutely.
Less water. And um,
I can truly say I never dedicated and layoffs.
Somehow the body just tightened up in May.
They had no ships pills that Gaza take silly.
Lilly would not go to the bathroom. Um,
I worried about those that were asked me to. Oh yeah. I was like,
Hey, for numerous reasons that the creative mind can think about,
but so I didn't, but my body never had. And then we never did it.
D and The d you guys didn't a TMI.
Did you guys, have you guys, did you guys use imagery at all?
Like overhead imagery? Nothing.
No. Um, some of the, uh, uh, gunk, the cobras,
no or no? Some of the, uh,
first CAV helicopters had some, I'm
trying to think what an IRR they would have. Um,
the ability to see through the clouds and style. Okay.
And it was just a very primitive boasts beginning whereas the Cobra gunships
didn't have it,
but the first calf could get low into the jungle and navigate in fog and stuff
to get down to our guys.
But no,
you guys wouldn't see photographs of the areas where you are going into at all?
No,
the only time was down in Cambodia for that missionar where that was.
Um, now that base was really close to Saigon,
close to McAfee headquarters and um, we may have had overviews.
I just forget for up north, that one down in there. I stuck.
It stuck in my mind.
And then what was your, what was your optempo like? In other words,
how often were you going in the field?
Well, through November, December, we, if we weren't on the,
if we weren't on the ground, we were getting ready to go back the next day.
That's why it was such a push, push,
push and I rotated or a little people out because they were just getting beat
and we had trained them up. So by November, December,
all the cross training we had done all those months, you know,
south could take a day off. Uh, even half could take a day off.
We had a couple of guys that could speak enough English if anything happened to
me or Baba, they could take care of the radio due to comms.
And, uh, so we rotated them through, but it was every day.
And then if the weather can we get a break? And, um,
so there was no, and the rule of thumb was if you ran a mission for five days,
you came back,
you got five days off so you could clean up and get back in shape,
get the team ready. But for that period of time,
we had minimal teams who the teams at fob one had become.
So between disease, um, health,
God's getting wiped out, teams getting blown away. Um,
we were one of the few teams and camp TDOT is fully operational.
So that's why I was the other pressure we had. Like I remember the me to saying,
hey, you only got to, we got your, you're going to say afternoon,
here's your target, go eat. Okay.
So we did it and then we got shot out and come back the next day.
And so there was no, this, the op temple was supposed to be robbed.
My Mr Five to 10 days if you're lucky. Well it never happened. Some guys did,
don't get me wrong, we had some guys that were able to stay on the ground.
Amazing. But in our case we didn't.
So it would be very flexible.
Didn't really take less than less than six guys. A few guys ran with four.
And uh, at the end of my tour of duty, a second tour,
I tried a four man team,
but we had this whole way she would do radio stuff just so we could move faster.
Just wanting to try anything. Something different.
Because when we had moved fast,
we had success getting away from the LZ and that caused them confusion.
So if we broke what our slps were, it worked.
But the eight man was too much. Too much. I felt more comfortable with sex.
It was a lot of firepower.
We had the m 79 near and then all the America's had DM city nines too.
And then how often would you get legitimate rnr?
Uh, you had one a year. One for a tour of duty.
You get five days anywhere you want it. So I went to Hong Kong,
bought my stereo bad and poker money. Sat Out. Paul,
Nice Stereo. Stady art sent home. No, mom and dad, they,
they and my little brother put it together. He was good at that stuff.
Uh, yeah, that's it. Other than that, there was no [inaudible].
If we had gotten that pow ah, then you would've gotten more here. We would have,
what was the offer for catching a bad guy? An rnr, anywhere in the world.
And then you've got her a a hundred dollar bonus. How many days? Five.
Like a regular rnr. Oh yeah, it was, oh yeah. That's why we lost it.
I cried when spider said no, a hundred bucks. How much was 100 bucks? How about,
how much was your normal paycheck? How much do you make a month back then?
Oh, I don't know. Um, when, when we went through jump school,
now I'm only a private e one. Right? I got 100% pay raise,
my jump pay because I was getting paid $50 a month. The jump pay was 55,
55 was a constant. Then later maybe he too was like 75.
I never paid, it was never enough.
So 100 bucks was like a hundred bucks. Was like a a month to pay basically. Yes.
Money even then a c note was a big deal. Absolutely.
And then when you guys would come back, you're talking about this,
how you would sit there and debrief, would you debrief your, your team,
would you guys sit down and debrief? What happened? What went wrong,
what went right?
We always talked to a little people. Um, maybe not right away because, uh,
as to would want to know what happened.
So we would go in for an immediate debrief, go back to the team,
make sure he had food for tonight and stuff and then go back for a final, uh,
after action report,
which would go through talking about everything from the vegetation,
a type of hills animals you encountered on a [inaudible].
Just crazy stuff. The foreigner, oh my God, the questions to his,
he was just after awhile I was like always the same. There's layoffs. Yeah.
Triple canopy is pretty dangerous. The NVA a pretty dedicated.
And then anything specifics off the target from the,
from that to take a learn from. How long,
how long did it take you to become the one? Zero well, my case,
um, I got in country, you may aspire to put me on a team at the end of May.
We trained June, July, uh, had a couple in country,
like little IAM bushes locally. And then we had a, uh,
the practice mission in August.
And then we did at first wiretap and not a wire tap, but the air force sensors.
We did two of those missions as September cause we had the monsoons too.
It's a lot of glue between the rain. We had like weeks, we would just rain.
Seemed like a rained every day. Ever see a horizontal rain?
Uh, yeah. Seen as much,
which are you guys would not run missions during the monsoon season. No,
you use too much. Too much. When you going to be too bad,
your saw your socked and you couldn't get out of the base. The to kink.
We couldn't get to the base. So how long, so how long was that?
Like four months before you were, yeah, four months. And, and,
and how many missions did you run before you are one? A one zero.
I had five missions under my belt. We had a two practice to two, um,
wiretaps and then don woken echo for,
and by that time, um, when he came to me he said, Yo, welcome,
got promoted to a copywriter and um,
cause pat walkers was leaving, there's an opening.
So he went there and they gave me option. Are you ready?
Well,
we a see what happened with Alabama with Lynn black in October when they put a
guy on a team that didn't have no experience.
So I talked it over with happened sal. I said, look, this the situation,
I don't know who they're going to give us. So we're about, I'll,
I'll be the one zero and spider had thought that was okay to do it,
talk to walk-ins and uh, they all said, well,
you're ready if you want to try it. And we didn't know who could,
they had new people coming into camp and some of these guys were the older ones
who had no experience on layoffs. We didn't want anything to do with them.
And it has, some of the younger guys are coming in.
Like I'm like Jim Robinson who was on a team for one mission and um,
we didn't know how to would stand up. So our guys were happy and,
and bubby came in and Bubba and the guy named the freshman, Doug Laterno,
the freshmen came in together and the freshman got picked for Virginia and I got
Bubba. They were buddies. They got be training group together. Yeah, that's
you.
So you'd been in the army for like a couple of years and younger in charge of a,
of a recon team. Yeah. Got in the army.
December 66 became a one zero on October 68.
So you figure years, almost two years. Yeah.
Cause the whole SF training between that and going through basic jumps school.
And then we had that uh, training before Vietnam d r t t training,
which was different, but that's just because we're Camo geeks.
Oh, the RTT training was just radio, radio teletype. Got It.
They want a top secret clearance men on those machines.
How much did you see the tactics that you guys were using
change over time?
Um, I think by the time, like when you read, we few by Nick Brock housing,
someone's guys were all carrying either rpds or an [inaudible].
So they were just going and heavier and um,
they would go into bigger team and um,
they were just anticipating the contact more whereas we thought we would try to
go in and try to escape and of aid and to the point where you hope he can get at
least some the mission done or to get some Intel reports about troop movements,
trucks, stuff like that or get a good wiretap.
So the biggest thing that changed was the guy started going in heavier and
actually bringing automatic weapons or belt fed machine guns. Sure.
That makes sense. I every single time I read any of your operations,
I want nothing more than a belt van machine gun. So do we use,
we didn't know who was going to carry yet. The seals had a, the stoner. Oh yeah.
Did you guys ever think about using that?
About it? A lot but, and it was a great system.
We heard many great reports about it, but again, the stoner system,
you needed audio ammo,
you had to get the supply system set up and we just weren't sure if we were
going to be able to get the guarantee if we converted, who would it be?
Just Americans.
We want everybody with common weapons so that if somebody gets blown up,
their weapon gets blown. Didn't know how to use the other guy's weapon,
your honor.
And you have the same magazines, same everyone's all that. Sure.
And what about the mission set itself?
Did you guys,
did you notice that change over time while you were there?
Later we began to get more point targets like in on the ground.
One of my favorite stories was, uh, the Frenchman.
He goes into a Cecile type mission. Um,
the CIA comes and says, we know about the NVA.
They're floating a 55 gallon drums down to river and to a storage area deep in
layoffs. So he wants you guys to go in, but we all trust you with the device.
They had a device that they screwed into a 55 gallon drum.
And so what we're going to do is, and that would be like a tracking device. No,
no explosive in nature. Oh that's right. That's right. Yeah. It's okay.
So here's what,
so we're going to meet you on this hilltop and lay us.
So Doug was the one one on a Rt. Virginia guther wall was the one zero.
They go in Hump three days, get to the mountain top.
There's the CIA with a couple guys. Okay, here's your device.
Go installed. Now come to the wall was a marine.
So you think that he'd be the guy doing a swimming, right? He goes,
I'm an e six freshman, you're an e for hit the work.
So the CIA gave to disclose the device, hump down the mountain,
get to the river and then now they're on a river with all the stuff gone by the
drums and some have NBA troops riding the drums or being present with a boat or
something. So in between artists, Doug strips down, goes in, gets a drum,
brings it back, puts in the explosive device,
swims it back out and it comes back soak and wet and not happy mean he's from
southern California. So He's, he's really not happy.
But two days later to get an extract it now to King Bees come extract and her
getting distracted as his use explosion and had sonic boom that literally moved
the aircraft and the guards were on the string swinging from the Sani.
Poon looked back, Derek goes a fueled up. Wow. Beautiful mission.
So those are kind of the point mission, the wire tactic in the pipelines.
We have more reports of pipelines and then also there are doing some trail work
trying to figure out how to re uh, look like it'd be a stream,
but they have things. That's one of our missions,
like the orchid mission to get in there to see,
well how to corner food splitter and can we use, go in and while you're there,
blow it up. May with a truck on it. Sure. Jack. Uh,
let's talk a little bit about gear. And you put,
you actually have a section in Sar chronicles and it's an across the fence to
where you talk about stuff you carry and stuff that you didn't carry. And uh,
some of the stuff that you didn't carry, no underwear, never.
No socks. Never.
And that's because you're just want to stay dry as much as possible. Yeah.
And both those things just hold water and keep moisture in. Yeah. And uh,
then black, uh, when he came,
all I had to made it was still on my underwear cause I went over with eight or
10 pair of the jockey shorts. Right. And it's,
so I was done on my last pair and the May was literally stealing.
Could they sell them on a black market?
They're relatively cleaned and relatively new.
Mom bought me a whole bunch of stuff and socks and everything.
So we had army socks. But, so anyways,
I talked to Len's L W I can't believe my mail has been still in my underwear
because we pulled down here the little I down, there's my underwear. So I said,
here,
take the last one and have good day and lingoes don't wear that stuff because
you get jungle rotten, crotch rot. And he says the same thing.
Put away your socks. Well,
you know if first couple of weeks the jungle boots were really tough on my feet,
but he was right there. And once you get a bunch,
get your feet broken in and your jungle boots broken in and so you go the water.
We did some of our in country stuff. We were in the rice patties. Oh my God.
But they would dry out quicker in have to worry about the socks.
So no helmet, never
no body armor. Nope. And your body armor sucked back back to its big clothes.
Just heavy. It didn't work well. It didn't work. Uh,
no intervention tool. Never. No bayonet,
no sleeping bag, no hammock, no Poncho, no Poncho liner, no ground pat. Correct.
You are not traveling for comfort. Never. We had to carry it.
As you know, you don't have that feeling.
What you take into the field you're carrying. You don't have your Mave with you.
Yeah. That that rucksack gets heavy too. So quick. Yeah.
And ours is like small. We had the indigenous rucksacks s and w.
And so once you put the radio and put the sweater underneath the radio so it
protect your back and they throw some rations, master a couple of extra ammo,
magazines and air.
And then extra hand grenades am setting nine rounds and a battery for galock
man. Yeah. You guys, uh,
no dog tags, no military id or idea of any kind. No rank, no name tags,
no jump wings, no CIB, no patches, no unit identifier, nothing.
No pictures of Mama. No pictures of Mama. Right? Totally slick.
So those are the things you didn't carry things you did carry car 15. Ah,
love it. You love the car 50.
Oh yeah, sorry. Back my second tour. A rock Myers was an s four. He's healed.
He had been wounded. I came back, he says, you're back.
Said I got a present for, he gave me a brand new car. 15. It was in a box.
Take it out. Stillness, audit, tinfoil and all the oils and greases and stuff.
And he'd take it out. Took it down to range. It was perfectly zero.
Never touched that with crazy.
Just put a little a cloth strap on it and went to work.
And, and you never had problems with that weapon? Never. Yeah,
they uh, did yours have a forward assist on it?
Did you support assist? Yeah, so that was uh, that was a car 15.
Wow. So the name 16 would it with a classical stock and a short and barrel.
Yeah. See it's weird.
So many people and myself being one of them complained about the car,
the car 15 or the end four frame and now the enforcer a lot nicer.
I made them forge a lot heavier till you got two rails and everything. Oh yeah.
Yeah. We can load things those out. They look like,
I think about a cigarette later on here. Some guys,
I wouldn't be surprised that they didn't have that on there too,
so that's awesome. You use the Cravat for your sling?
Yes. Sato well, yeah, I did that a door.
My second tour could it had to crevasse quiet and, and then, uh,
God forbid if he ever needed a cravat and closed Caribou.
I always wore one around my neck, had one on my head. And then one on the car,
15 of course you carried, we
had Corvettes in case as a very bottomed, a rucksack we would get is sort of a,
one of those things that never wear a sling.
And some guys would say that get caught up. And that's just, man,
especially when you're in a leadership position, you need a sling,
cause you gotta look at your map, you've got to pull out, you know,
you've got to do stuff, you know.
And the other thing is you don't have a slang and you get blown up. Yeah. Get,
where's your weapon? You have no idea when you wake up. So, yeah. Um,
but then there's some, you know, some people just, they wouldn't carry a slang.
Mark Leaves one machine gunner seed, just no slang. Nope. That was like, man,
the thing to do was no slang.
All of them 60 or these days of mark 48 really? Yeah. Yeah.
Uh, how strong this guy strong, strong,
and the 79 you carried sawed off. Oh yes.
I cannot believe that. Me and my guys did not think of selling off our,
I'm 70 guys cause I guarantee guys would've sought off the end.
I said well yeah, my first self afflicted wound was from a solid off m 79.
What'd you do? Well we're in a process of cutting them down.
So the question was how far he cut the barrel down.
So we finally cut it right down to the last hinge where on?
It's the last one that's to the bottom of the frame. Got It. So you crack it,
put the round and so we kept bringing it back. So we're down to range.
We're there. And the question was, because you cut the barrel off,
it needs the number of rotations. Now are our weapons guys knew that.
But I was,
me and Rick Howard were comma guys and I didn't really ask the question was
fired. She, so on this day I fire it fairly close,
it goes being popped in I noise instead of nine makes and then it went all like
pop bang like that. And I go, Oh damn.
So I go to Rick Harrison, I think a B just hit me. He pulled my strips,
he had dumb ass usually shot yourself. My first self-inflicted moon.
But the good news was that I'm sitting,
I worked and then of course we cut the handle down to just have enough to you
could hold on to because that way is less less weapon.
You still had all the firepower that cut that weapon down by half. Oh yeah.
I was looking at the pictures you have, but in your book it's,
that thing is tiny, tiny but effective. Charlie hated those things.
And at one point you had a, you had a holster for that thing. Yeah.
John Wayne. That's still, that's still in layoffs with my a saga knife.
A I had it, somebody had crafted it and I put it on. It's, yeah,
that was perfect. But uh, never had a dull.
But from that point I just like everybody else, we just carried on those d-ring.
We taped it. So be quiet though.
You carry 34 20 round mags each path,
each with 18 rounds each. So that's 612 rounds for good luck. Yeah.
And so that's how he carried extra like a,
with a couple of extra clips and in case we needed to reload the uh,
34 magazines. And you went on,
you mentioned you had few missions where you are down to your last one or two at
least twice. I remember echo four was the first time.
Did you always hang onto your magazines when you are out at dependent on the
degree of intensity of the firefight. If I had time, we keep best for a happy,
I'll bring back my damn magazines. Did you stuff on your shirt? Yeah.
Yeah cause the web gear would be tight. So uh, I don't know.
Our jungle fatigues. We're out. Yeah.
So you had the pants, but then the harness from the, uh,
in a web gear with everything in when I came in we'd stuffed magazine,
our shirt and then, but with body armor you can't do that.
So now guys carry like pouches or just dropping their leg cargo pockets or
whatever. Yeah.
And our preferred thing would have bar bells because you could put four
magazines in and one across the top. And it was a nice pouch.
The bar belts that they have from World War II,
perfect for the a 20 round magazines, that's a lot of just,
you know,
we would normally carry seven to 10 30 round mags.
So we carried like, I mean sometimes I guess more than that, but not no,
600 rounds where you were anticipating being alone for awhile. No,
we weren't fighting divisions worth the people either. So
yeah, it, you know, and I guess we did,
what we did have is we always had heavy machine guns, you know,
so that makes a big difference too. I guess. You know,
we would have mark 48 which is seven six two and then the mark 46 which is five
five 60 let's,
that's basically like a little stoner and a and m and 60 the modern versions of
those two things. But yeah, so we had assault too, right? Yeah.
Well that's the mark 46 is a song. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Um,
yeah. So we had those and those guys would carry a lot of browns,
a lot arounds like 800 to a thousand sometimes more on the kid like that.
Over a thousand. Yeah. And I had guys go,
Winchester go run out of bullets. Really? Yeah. With that many.
So yeah, I guess maybe that was the differentiator.
You carried 10 to 12 frag grenades.
That's a lot of frag grenades,
I guess when you're going and picking fights with divisions,
you've got to carry a lot of for aggregates. Oh yeah.
And they always kept the last one. That was the one up here,
just in case it'd be appealed. W uh Huh. Oh yeah, absolutely.
We would carry, I don't know. Well I would carry like a one or two.
Well, how often would you be? I just got laughed at it's official. Don't laugh.
How often would you, how often would you need more than two then?
Hopefully never, you know, and especially I'm in a leadership position,
I'm hopefully hucking grenades, but uh,
yeah, no, you know, the big difference, especially in Ramadi, I mean in Ramada,
I remember explaining to the guys that relieved us, you know,
we had a big overhead imagery and I put my hand on the map and I said,
no matter where you put your hand on this map,
you'll be touching a friendly unit. So like in, you know, this is, you know,
probably within three to 500 meters of you anywhere you were in reminder,
there's a friendly unit. Really. So that's why, you know,
you are going to get reinforcement, you're going to get tanks,
you're going to get Bradley fighting vehicles. So yeah.
But in between that time, you earned your pay half to earn your pay. Yeah. Uh,
yeah, I was talking to late life. That's another thing.
So it was Lafe Lafe Scout,
a chapter in dichotomy of leadership where he's talking about preparing over
prep, over preparing for too many contingencies and he talks about,
it was his first patrol out on,
outgoing out with the marine corps and a daytime patrol.
And he's talking about how much stuff he cared, he cared all this stuff.
But one of the things he carried as you know,
eight grades or something like that and you know,
he reflects on how that was. We just way too many. I was like, hey man,
you know, tilted, go out in the field with less than 10
so definitely a io did are grenades.
I wonder how much you would have changed if you had to wear body armor or if you
would have decided not to or whatever. You know, it's interesting.
That's an interesting development.
If we even had today's stady art never would have worn it to,
it's just too much weight and you have to be able to move. I mean, you know,
eventually you're so damn lucky, no bullets are going to hit you. Yeah.
That's why I crawled a lot trying to keep the little profile, but uh, no,
I probably would have declined it because of the weight as it was, uh,
in our AAO. Maybe another AOE with different situations,
more flexibility with assets. And the,
the thing that's interesting is one of the reasons why you wear a helmet now
isn't just to protect your head.
It's because that's where your nods mount onto your night vision.
My vision mount onto your, so you,
they do have a contraption that's like a headband looking thing.
I don't even think they make it anymore, but, but where you could wear that,
but you know, your nods mount on your, your night vision mounts on your helmet,
your, that's just the way it is. I've seen those.
Ciliates we've got fist down and dogs. That's really cool. I want one too. Yeah.
Yeah. That's go time when those thoughts flipped down. All right.
But instead of wearing a helmet, you wore a corvette,
the green for that green curve out on your head, one around your neck. You had,
you wore regular army fatigues. Yeah.
There's sterile fatigues that had, um,
a Tupacs up top with an angle and to pockets down here to hung out.
And then we customize them. We had, um,
the tailor put in pockets here. So for mirrors, maps,
morphine, serviettes, Sasol close
right here.
And then we had a pockets on each arm that put other things up.
There were pinned flares, other things from Google that,
that we did too. So we did even before, even the nineties before the everyone,
because now the fatigues come issued with pockets on the arms and everything,
but we used to take them off and so I'm on. And that's where you'd keep your,
your pans and your notebooks and your pen flares near and your signal mirror.
Yeah. And then on the ones on your chest, you had maps and morphine,
your extra notebook, your, you are see 10 emergency radio.
Yeah.
And then you had a, you wore a watch. A Seiko. Yeah.
Aluminous watch you work gloves. Always.
Yeah.
Just cut out the thumb index finger. Then the middle finger, just cut it to tip.
So you grabbed a tape on the magazine sort of firefighters? Yep. Same thing.
Same thing we would do, but you always wear gloves or gloves.
Otherwise your hands are just getting destroyed out. Oh jungle. Forget about it.
Yeah Cause Lot of times we wind up get, get a new pair of gloves.
We just get torn up so much in the jungle and fatigues those, wait a minute,
wait a minute of vines and the thorns because you know there are, wait a minute,
when you get caught into it, if you walk into your leg, goes into the pins,
just come together.
So you had to stop and then get the pins to get your leg out.
Otherwise it goes deeper into your, into your leg.
What about, did you carry any kind of mosquito net for your head? No. How come?
Cool.
Never thought about it. And mosquito net for the head.
Yeah. Well I used to, this was like the most brilliant thing.
I think it was an Australian guy told me this you I would to have like a little
square of mosquito netting [inaudible] and when we would stop patrolling,
I would take out that little square, put it over my head,
right over my right over my floppy hat and talk it in and all of a sudden you're
not getting chewed apart by mosquito.
Oh yeah. Good. One night we,
the one time we did a practice mission east of the Asheville in the morning I
couldn't, I couldn't open, my eyes have been bitten so much. Great.
By mosquitoes. My face was puffed out. You need that mosquito. I needed to help.
Had I only known, I sort of thought about her. Talk about that. Yeah.
I had a guy,
we were doing some training and none of us had mosquito netting except for the
officer. And so the officer was sleeping heartedly like just fully.
And one of the other young listed guys was catching mosquitoes and putting them
inside this guys, while he was asleep,
he woke up covered in this valley.
Those mosquitoes were trapped in there with them. They were trapped in there.
They couldn't get out. They were just having a feast trapped Hungary,
mosquitoes, mosquitoes. Yeah. So, but no, not for you know,
mosquito net. No, I hadn't thought about that one.
Leeches.
Oh
you guys ran into a lot of leeches. Always.
Yeah, we had the a bug repellent for that.
And so would even read the bug repellent on him once you got sucked on by a
Leech. Yeah, they would instantly fall. But you always try to wait,
try to see if he could jiggle them off because you knew that wee bugbee pound
could be smelled by bad guys. So
then you had your on your web gear,
which was the old World War II web gear you had on your left harness.
You had your k bar handled down or a saga knife or saga knife until you lost it
too. I love, that's what we need to do. A recovery mission four.
Get that site back. Yes.
A handle down. Sure. That's how you rolled it.
Cause this way you pull it out and you're ready. What's up period?
He's deployed out in the jungle. You might get caught up in the vines. Got It.
Got It. Uh,
you had hand-grenades there cause you were basically covered in hand grenades.
Oh yeah. Uh, smoke you had there,
you had some, some bandages there on your right harness.
You had your strobe light, you had more hand grenades,
you had your d ring and you had more smoke grenades.
Then on your belt you had one canteen. Usually
depending on the target, sometimes it'd be maybe two, but usually one.
And then one I had a second one in my, in my backpack rucksack.
You normally wouldn't get, what'd you get thirsty?
Was there normally enough water in the jungle? Wasn't as bad as Cambodia.
So, but yeah, you get thrust cause you're humping up and down. Um,
there's a couple times we particularly in that day we went straight up with the
orchids. That was a day we got we all out of water.
Not Fun. No. So you had one canteen, you had a Willy Pete grenade,
you had your survival acts,
which was the Franklin Warren survival acts type two and d.
That's type one wasn't mine. I wanted to type two.
I looked him up and had like a hook at the top. Yeah.
Another Blaine you went through when you came back on the, on the back pool,
you could try to make it effective to cut up, particularly with cutting vines.
That thing came with you all the time. Every mission.
I got it home onto my desk right now, a case and the tutor comes in, I'm ready.
I like, it just isn't true.
There's feeling lucky luck.
You meet Mr. Tilt compass around your neck.
You used a corvette for your belt. Yes.
So the belt I was talking about before is the belt of your web gear,
but just the health of your pants was just a, was a corvette.
You carried a Swiss army knife, you carry the gas mask always.
You always carried a gas mask.
We had teams that got hit and the in camps that had been hit by the enemy used
to. Yes, sure. And they use,
I forget what the incidents war, but there
were a couple times that the enemy had used gas on our people in Lagos as well
as with a CIA operation. Now, we weren't told that,
but we had cold evidence that they had done it and that they could hit one of
our recon teens. So we had to carry that bulky ass thing at all times.
I was going to say, but, and this is, this was the, the concern was tear gas.
Well, tear gas or who else knows what they had? I mean these are common.
It's tough to play by rules of engagement. Yeah.
I mean I'm not in Laos cause yeah,
that's what I was thinking with all this crap that you're carrying.
And a gas master. Just huge and bulky. Yeah.
Left hip out to where I got all the time.
Had to and we used them uh, twice. And uh,
um, we in, we had designed a mission, one of our missions was to,
when we got distracted from a target, an m, a target,
we saw a road to had, um,
little guard station, a guard station, but it was north of the DMZ river.
So the quest for getting, um,
alive pow.
We found out that he had one of our guys that did a VR and flew a couple rooms
and he saw these little waste stations along the way.
So our thought was we'll get gas, gas him. And they said he had a,
a knockout gas at the time. Right.
So we practiced for a couple of days with tear gas and he had to get the
helicopter policy and the gun crews,
everybody would do mass and didn't have master.
They could talk to each other and then talk to us. And um,
so we practiced for several days training with the helicopters coming in the Ed
and the mission plan was go up in the middle of the day,
go to one of those camps, hit it, gas it, go in and scarf mountain, go home,
get a five day pass and a hundred bucks. Yeah. But they, uh,
and they had a special knockout cast that were supposed to use and at the end
they, they, they wouldn't let us,
they wouldn't give us the gas or I don't know if they had it,
but they wouldn't give us the knock out kiss.
So then another mission came up too.
We had a bright light to run and we never got back to the concept of doing it.
And you carried, uh, you usually carried one grenade for your 40 Mike, Mike.
That was tear gas. Always sure case we needed it. And that was, what would your,
what would your tactic be on using that? Usually it would be two, uh,
um,
no to create disorder because you hit somebody with tear gas eva as far away
[inaudible] that would distract them for a second,
take her mind off of business or at least make them have a harder time to kill
us. And we also carried a grass gas grenade, local. Okay.
So we had in our sop, uh,
procedure that the word will have to go to Hegel was,
but we had a signal or a sign for his cs gas.
So if we're getting so overrun to where the papa cs to break the break the
charge with of our teams dead, um,
they used it in and the operation tailwind quite effectively save your bacon.
So the idea would be, hey, this is going to linger.
Whereas a frag grenade, it goes off.
You either wound guys or you don't you the kill guys or you don't,
but that's it. It's over.
Whereas gas you can really disrupt them because now you got guys coughing and
puking or whatever
and as an and hangs to the ground and then it hangs around as long as the wind
is going to let it hang around.
Got It. Left pant pocket. You had a marking panel. Large and small,
right pant pocket pen flares, d d hydrated alert ration,
bug repellent for Leeches, an extra caveat and extra bandage.
Did Anybody Carry Ivy?
A several guys did. Okay. Uh, Lynn black did and um,
we had I think South Carolina, one of our in ditch carry one.
We had an IB and the um, St line solution that came in a canister,
she always had one in case we needed it.
In your rucksack, you got your, you got your PRC 25,
which you guys called the district 25. Yeah, I think I was,
I think I was outlawed from calling it a prick that, that PRC 25.
So the PRC 25 was replaced by the PR 77 the preps 77 and I want to say it was
1969 or something like that. When I got to seal team one,
that's what I used was a pew.
It was one of the radios that we had in our inventory. It was a PRC 77. Yeah.
Which came directly from the PRC 25. So you'd carry that,
you had the big whip antenna, but you wouldn't,
you'd have the little tape antenna on there so you don't identify it as the
radio guy cause otherwise you're gonna know,
pulled it over. In our case, the antenna, we just get it and bend it down,
come up with your arms, stick it into the fatigues. So be low profile on.
Then you had a, your your one sea rat of fruit. Oh,
that was like your, that was, that was your, your goto indeed.
And you'd carry one of those, two of those, something like that.
Uh, usually just one. Cause after a while, you know,
we kept getting shot out so often it's like, okay, I'm not too much weight.
Yeah, yeah. Uh, yet, act, do you add your extra mags and every,
you got an extra m 79 browns,
you had your army long sleeve sweater, you had a plastic rain jacket,
toilet paper, even though you apparently never used it. Correct.
But you could also use it to pack wounds. There you go. Uh,
extra battery for the,
for the prick 25 and the URC 10
extra smoke grenades, uh, extra canteen, water,
extra ration.
And then you had your claymore or claymores with five and ten second fuses.
And on top of that, the 22 caliber hush puppy on some operations sometimes.
Yeah. And all this, when you'd weighed yourself, you'd be about 90 pounds heavy
right around there. Yeah. And it was a, it was an old brick SKL scale.
So I just jumped on it and everything just to see what it,
well that's a heavy load out. I'll tell you right now, that's a heavy load out.
That is absolutely all of 90 pounds.
When you start talking about 600 rounds of ammunition and we start talking about
10, 10 to 12 hand grenades, smoke, smoke, grenades are heavy as hell.
They got all that material in them that smokes. Sure. They're big giant beasts.
And a Willie Peter was the Willie piers heavy too.
Uh, uh, crazy mouth. Um,
and I guess like I said, and like you said,
you're carrying all that fire power because the operations,
you're carrying a crazy amount of fire power cause you're doing crazy
operations.
Yeah. And again, from talking to other ones, Zeros, pat walkers and McGovern,
cause initially I don't know what the loads were,
but they kept increasing it because there were several times and he ran out of
ammo already got close to running out as the last thing in the world. You want,
you know?
Yeah. Awesome. Well,
you know, that's a little over two hours right now and it's been a quick night.
Yeah, indeed. Indeed. But, um,
you got any, you got any closing thoughts?
No. Uh,
just to thank you for have me in three times and we've gained some extra tech.
Like I said before, uh,
we were just chatting is say the stories always felt war significant in terms
of, uh, the stories about what saga did and the men, more importantly men.
And also, like I said to you earlier, my stuff is hairy,
but if you had a Harry scale on one to 10,
I mean I feel I put myself at a five or six compared to the guys that got the
metal bond, a guys that didn't come home that went down fighting,
getting over run buddy and VA. And we,
we can just talk about metal Bonner missions of guys standing there just
fighting off and dying on Elz putting their people on a hill,
a copter first John Kaedan Berg, Johnny Gal Hoon time and again,
RSF God would take care of the little people, even get 'em on to chopper,
get 'em out. And uh,
so those stories I felt with great valor. And um,
so I thank you for the little extra [inaudible]
to your audience. Well, we appreciate that. We'll, we'll,
we'll bring you back on and we'll get,
and I know you and I are talking about other guys that were going to come on and
all those stories of those heroes. We'll,
we'll get them out there because people want to know. I want to hear them.
I want to know as much as I can about them and, and, and you know, we'll,
we'll get you back.
Well, I'm ready to roll, so thank you. And I thank you for the time.
Also, you're on a, you're like Mr social media now. I didn't realize that you
have to give me a full briefing when we're done. So you're on Twitter,
you and Echo Charles. Get me squared away. You're on Twitter.
We haven't quite figured out Twitter yet. Apparently you're,
that makes two of us. You're old.
Your old Twitter handle was at saga chronicles.
Your new Twitter handle is at John Stryker Meyer.
That's, that's where it's at right now. Yes sir. That's right. All right.
So people will start trying to communicate with you on that. Good luck.
I'm going to call it a presence aid president Trump.
Could you help me out on my Twitter for president Trump tweets all the time to
king of Twitter. He is. He is. Hey, I was, I'm sorry. No,
you'll be able to, you'll be able to you when you,
that's the incredible thing about Twitter is everybody has a platform.
It's incredibly good. Sometimes it's in PR incredibly bad,
but everybody has a platform so no. The cool thing about it is people have been,
you know,
talking to me and hitting me up and just thanking you for your service,
thanking you for coming on.
Thank you for sharing the stories so it will be cool that they'll be able to
actually thank you.
Instead of just telling me to tell you things and just go to a website,
they've got the link in there for email for the old fashioned route.
Saw chronicles.com saw chronicles.com airborne. Yeah.
People were the people on there. I wanted to close out reading. One last thing,
and this is your,
your dedication for the book saw chronicles one and it said,
it says,
this book is dedicated to the SOG men and they're courageous indigenous team
members who went across the fence and to allow us Cambodian north Vietnam during
the eight year secret war and to the and to the brave aviators and crew members
of
the Army Air Force Marine Corps and our fearless allies from the 219th south
Vietnamese Air Force Special Operations Squadron,
the legendary King Bees who supported who supported SOG teams on the ground.
This book is also for every man in SOG and the aviators who made the ultimate
sacrifice far outside the boundaries of conventional Vietnam War that America
saw reported on the nightly news.
A good two closing note apps today,
1,598 Americans that are mia and Southeast Asia from the Vietnam War.
50 Green Berets alone in layoffs are still mia,
including 140 plus avs at dyes strictly supporting our mission.
And this week,
the National League appeal w Mia Found was having his 50th annual meeting in uh,
Arlington on this topic. They'd been diligent and uh,
and mills Griffiths is the CEO. She's putting it all together.
They work with the Pentagon.
She had been on this mission from day one and our prayers are with them to
continue because they're pushed to bring our people home. Absolutely.
And if you want to put that out either on SOG, chronicles,
put a link to how people can support that cause people will absolutely support
that cause. Oh, okay. We'll do that. So they deserve, yes, absolutely.
We can make that happen. Oh, thank you. Airborne. All right, well like I said,
you haven't opened an invite on here. Anytime you want,
you let us know we're here and we'll get some of your friends on and thanks for
coming on yourself.
Thanks for sharing your stories and most of all more than anything else,
thanks for your service and sacrifice. Likewise brother, you've been there,
you've seen Neil often appreciate it.
And once again,
John Stryker Meyer has left the building. Tilt kilt has left the building.
Okay.
Finishing up three podcasts with John Stryker Meyer.
Yeah.
Sappers sappers I asked them what sappers was where,
cause there was various references for a second and this past one,
two sappers end more notably one.
If you remember the movie Predator,
the first one he says sappers those sapper has been on a sense, blah, blah,
blah, whatever. The interesting, and I always wondered what's a sapper.
Okay.
Special Group, Vietnam,
North Vietnamese group of anti American fighters trained specifically.
Right,
right. I got that right. Right. Did I remember that correctly? Yeah, that's,
that's the definition that John Stryker Meyer just gave you
anyway. All right, cool. What else Jocko? Well
I would say no. Awesome. Awesome.
To have a John Stryker Meyer on here and just to hear him talk about what human
beings can do, right. What people,
human beings can do.
And it's interesting cause you ever look at dogs and you think, oh,
there's a little tiny Chihuahua and then there's like a, a German shepherd.
Yeah. And you think those are the same animal, right? Yes. They are.
Technically,
technically human beings seem like you look at John Stryker Meyer.
He's like a German shepherd. Yeah.
And then you've got people running around there. Chihuahuas,
no offense against the Chihuahuas, but you're sure why was not gonna yes.
Fend off hoards. Chihuahuas, not calling in airstrikes,
danger clothes. No.
So I guess my point is that human beings do have capabilities and I think that
when you listen to tilt,
you realize that I can probably do better. I know.
That's what I realized. I think, yeah, I can do better than I'm doing right now.
Yeah. I think I can, I can push the envelope a little bit. Yeah.
[inaudible]
move further toward the potential.
The part that kind of will probably will stick with me is how he didn't carry
Poncho, like the sleeping style company. It was just like, Oh,
if we have to go sleep, I'm just going to sleep right here in who? In the end,
on the ant hill, this, whatever.
See that part when I was a kid,
when I was a kid that was viable. But now you need comfort.
Yeah. I'm weak. Yeah.
So that part that maybe I have to mentally maybe work on that, you know.
All right, let's face it, there are ways to get better.
Yesterday there is maybe sleeping without a ground pad is one of them. Yeah.
Maybe another one is train Jujitsu. Oh yeah, big time.
That's a, I mean, so I was training the other day with Noah Oliver, right.
And Noah's been training and he's kind of sorting out, you know,
how you go in phases of training partners. You know, he'd been bad man.
I've been training with Andy for like the last like three months,
you know more than so man.
But he's been like beat me down the other day yesterday,
yesterday, day before whatever. And Yeah, he beat me down.
But at the same time I didn't leave thinking like, oh my gosh,
get your socks. You know when you get beat down you think of, okay,
what do I need to do to that's the correct data. TF. Well especially,
well when you have training partners that you like and you trust and you,
you know, you enjoy what you get from the training or whatever.
Regardless you got beat down or not, I think you might audit.
We'll start to automatically go to that.
I think most of the time it's usually when, I don't know other circumstances.
Then you'd be all salty and make excuses or something like that. Either way.
So I'm thinking, you know,
of all the things and then I arrive at the concept of men in any other
situation. You take that kind of like just physical turmoil.
Not only do you get beat, but it was like kind of hard, you know?
Usually I don't feel this good about it.
I'm not looking forward to the next time, you know like come on, let's face it,
you do a hard metcon, you're like boom. I'm glad that's over with.
But in this case you are looking forward, Tom. Excellent. Yeah.
You're looking forward to the next one.
You look forward to just training more in general.
There's a short term and long term pay off for this Jujitsu thing.
Interesting. Oh yeah. Very true.
Not to mention the capability that you wind up with.
So we're pro Jujitsu is what we're dedicated.
We're a hundred thousand percent short term and longterm there's no,
there's no dichotomy. There's just short term gain. Longterm game. Yes,
in my opinion, but it could be argued that, oh, it's hard. What about the Dagon?
What about sometimes when people don't want to train,
they let the Jujitsu window close like we confirmed as a thing. It is a thing,
but that's, you know what I kind of arrived at as well.
The days that you actually don't want to train are way rare
than you might think. Like have you ever said, man,
I really don't feel like training. And then you make the drive to the gym,
you get to the gym, your training partners show up.
You right when you go to shake hands and you still feel like,
oh I really don't want to train her in August. That's never happened. Never.
Right. Hardly ever. I can't think of one single time I've thought.
I came to the gym one time and I got there and I was like,
I still don't want to train.
But it was because there was only like three people there and they were like
really brand new at the time and then I was like, oh,
and I just went home one time in my whole life. But wow,
I did. I legitimately did not feel like training anyway. Legitimately.
Usually if you don't feel like training,
it's not that you don't feel like that's never happened.
It's not that you don't feel like training, it's,
you don't feel like getting off the couch, getting into your car,
getting your gear, getting, you know, doing that.
That's what you don't feel like doing. Oh,
you feel like training because when it's time to train,
it's good fun every single time. That's what I think.
It's a weird aspect that you do too, is fun. This is very fun. It's fun. Yeah.
I have a feeling something I was going to trade. You did too,
where I'm literally like kind of beside myself with how fun that just,
you know,
and that's sometimes I'm getting beat down and I'm thinking that sometimes I'm
winning and I'm thinking, but either way I'm like, God, that was, yeah, it's,
it's kind of like, uh, a feeling that's very hard to,
to describe even. Yeah, I would,
I would agree with that. Yeah.
Cause you have that obviously the physical part of it, right? Exercise. Yes.
That's always good. And you know that. But this is like, it's like press,
especially if he roll with like guys who are like, good,
then they're not good because they're so athletic.
Even though they might be athletic, they're good because they know what to do.
Like a dean lister, like Greg McIntyre, these guys who like Greg Trey,
if he Greg chain,
if you don't think your way into or out of the situation you want,
man, you're, you're just not going to do it. You know?
So it's that problem solving task that's just intertwined in the whole thing.
I think that's what makes it fun. That's what I think agree. Anyway. G,
Nogi streets, whatever. If you want to do, Gee, you're going to need a g,
you get a g from origin or do you mean.com as we can get to keep very selections
on there. The best made in America by the way. Made in America. Yeah,
and just kind of massive shipment of cotton and I'm not,
I'm talking not talking to woven. I'm talking unwoven little strands of cotton.
Check out, check out, check out the Instagram.
There's pallets and pallets that are there and it's just you think, okay,
this cotton is going to get woven and then turned into gifts that I'm going to
wear. What does cotton look like when it comes from pallets?
Because we want to just little spools of, and it's not even,
it's not just cotton by the way, it's, it's a blended,
so totally modern spring, like a spool, but it's thick, a little bit thicker.
That all gets woven together.
We used to grow cotton when I was young in her yard and quiet. Really?
[inaudible] for what purpose? That's just how I guess, I don't know.
Did I do something with, I dunno, random. It was there.
It was a row of cotton trees. So cotton is like a,
it's like a, almost like a pod that turns inside out like a popcorn almost.
Yeah, if I remember correctly. And so that cotton would be balls of cotton,
you know, like you get, you know when you buy cotton balls, right? Yeah.
I'm sure you always buy cotton balls, but when you buy the cotton balls,
they're in balls. They're kind of like that, but more like, uh, there's not,
they're not in a ball. They're in a big clump. Okay. There's seeds all in there.
You gotta pick out the seeds and the seeds are all stuck to the content.
I thought that's how they came. But they're,
they're twined in or spun into string. All right.
We got cotton, we've got geese, we got jeans also. I got jeans by the way.
Oh Sir. You're in the game now.
I'm totally in the game and I'm surprised how good. Okay, good American Dan.
I'm sure the buttons, brass origin buttons. I was impressed with that.
When I saw the pictures, when I see them, I'm impressed,
but I'm maybe I'm more surprised on top of the impressed of how they fit next
level.
I thought they were going to be like the kind of older just generic fitting
worker jeans, which is fine. I get it,
but that's not really what I was like deep down hoping for.
I was hoping for the kind that, you know, I can put on, I can wear to, you know,
if I go somewhere special with my wife or something like that.
You're just putting on those origins jeans. Stoke. There's good. Yes.
They're very good. They fit good. Hand it to Pete. Yeah,
that stylish fashioned dude. Little bit
skinny. Nice tee shirts, jeans,
Ghees rash guards, joggers, supplements. Yes. Supplements.
Get your joint warfare, get your Krill oil,
get your discipline, get your discipline,
go get these things. They will. They will.
They will make your life better. As crazy as that sounds,
they will make your life better as will moke. Yes,
and some people say, what is smoke? And the answer is very clear. Mulkey is
Moelleken's moment. That's right. MOCA smoke.
You can't just call it something you can't call.
You can't call a knife by some other name. Right. It's a rash tonight,
so you can't call milk. You can't say milk is something else. No,
milk is milk. Then again, I'm in Hammond Devil's that picky.
You can't call the knife up shank. Okay, I'll bleed. Yeah, you're right.
Cold Steel. You know there's a lot of words for knife cutting.
So there's other words for for milk then is what you're saying? No,
I'm not saying that. As you know,
just say Mark [inaudible] is a dessert in the shape of a protein powder that's
healthy. Okay. So you can either call it that or you can call them milk.
It tastes like dessert and yet it's good for you and gives you protein.
Strawberry is delicious. Mint chocolate chip. I had to,
I had so much strawberry, I had to go back to men and I was like, good Lord,
man. It's crazy. Men is delicious. What do you want?
Mint chocolate chip ice cream milkshake or do you want a mint milk? Oh,
I'll take the mint milk all day long. Oh yeah. Short and longterm payoff.
Short and longterm payoff. Peanut butter. Reese's cup.
I don't know if you're allowed to say Reese's cup,
but that's basically what it is. Peanut butter. Reese's cup.
But it's peanut butter and chocolate milk. Tasty. You know,
what am I missing? Vanilla. I'm not a vanilla guy.
I don't like the Vanilla Yogurt. I don't like the vanilla. The vanilla milk is,
it's, if you like vanilla, you're good. If you don't really like vanilla,
you know, don't get it. There's a whole hoard of Vanilla Lakers. Yeah,
for sure. And the thing that's cool about vanilla, I guess,
is that you can do other things with it. Jason Gardener put it in your morning.
Coffee. Yeah. Hit it with the, he likes to say, hit it with the blenders stick.
Right. You know people, some people like to say things, he's like,
I hit it. He gets all fired up through. I hit it with that blender stick.
He calls it a blender stick. So there Jason Gardner. So, and,
and Jason Garners in great shape getting after it.
Yeah. So maybe it a,
maybe it's a positive thing and don't forget that there's warrior kid milk.
Cause do you want to feed your child poison? No.
Do you? I do not. Okay, cool. Then you get a milk.
Do you want your kid to to be miserable when they eat because what you're
feeding them tastes disgusting. Let me think. No. Okay cool.
So you gave give him milk and you know,
being healthy and you're taking care of your kid and you're actually being a
good parent. Yeah.
Otherwise you're neglecting your child's welfare. Don't do it. Yeah. Milk,
strawberry milk, chocolate milk, get some, it's true.
My daughter in this phase,
hopefully short where like she's comparing her body with like other people's
body. Oh yeah. That'll be a short phase. It only lasts like 500 years.
So man, it kind of makes you think like, oh shoot,
she's paying attention now that she's looking at your guns. Like whatever.
Anyway, uh, so more you over in the corner doing curls,
pushups and actually she does burp. Like you know what I tell her it's,
it's kind of a trick. I don't know. Tell me if you think this is a lie.
So she'll be like, hey, I don't really feel like doing the workout today.
So I say, okay,
you don't have to do the workout if and only if you do burpees,
input ups,
kind of like burpees and push ups are not gonna work even though that is the
workout. Oh yeah. It's like 70 burpees in uh,
like 40 pushups or something like that. That's the whole workout.
I make a six year old. Do you know, full on metcon or nothing like that.
But I say, you don't have to do the workout.
You only have to do the push on them versus he's like, okay, you know,
kind of like she escaped the workout even though that is where he is.
That lying, this flanking, right? Like yeah. Hell yeah.
Then the last one point that's authorized. Good. Yes. Anyway,
my point is that yeah, once you know when, when you know you a still girl,
being conscious of how her body looks in all this stuff and be makes utilizes
six man.
And I kind of feel this overwhelming responsibility, like,
hey,
if she starts like putting on weight that she doesn't like or something like
that, it's Kinda my fault. You know? At this point it is for sure. So the milk,
you can, I feel real good about it, especially that she likes it, you know?
And that stuff, everyone is, I don't know how they did that, but keep doing it.
That's what I know. Anyway. Also, Jocko white tea. Yes.
Can you get addicted to Jocko white tea? The answer is yes. Yeah.
Yes. It's psychological JP to know.
JP knows my brother currently addicted to talking about about him.
I'm saying the boys got a little bit of an addiction problem with the juggle it.
All right, well, there you go. And I mean,
I'm sure I haven't thought about it that much,
but I'm sure there is some drawbacks to being addicted to Jocko at Haiti.
I don't know. But from here, I mean, the intuitive thought is that men,
that's all upside addicted to good stuff. You know, it's like I,
I'm addicted to Jocko white tea and I have an 8,000 pound deadlift.
How's it going? Yeah, probably way more now. Yeah. Like 1200 or something. Sure.
I'll ask them anyway. You talk white tee is available cans as well. Uh,
tea bags as well on the store. It's on the store. It's on Amazon.
It's everywhere. Get it. But it's up there. Yeah, for sure.
Get your addiction on something good. Also, we have our own store.
Speaking of the stores called Jocko store,
this is where you can get this willing equals freedom shirts. Like I said,
Jocko white tea is on the store that's on the store. Tens refills,
all that stuff. Hoodies, lightweight and heavyweight hats. Rash guards,
rash guards. Oh, big time. Yeah. Well yeah,
if you want to represent the path while you're on the sport and a rash guard
today, when I was doing ring workout wearing, I was,
we're using the rings and if you don't wear a rash guard when you're doing
rings, if you do high reps, you'll start to chafe your arms a bunch,
which is no big deal. But then you get like, you know, you're,
if you're doing Jujitsu and then you're starting to get a little infection
exposures going on. So just words, rash card. Yeah. Also, you know,
if you work at the bank or somewhere where people sort of half deaf have at
least a little bit of trust in you.
If you're willing around with chafed hands and arms and stuff,
they're like not brown. What's up with this kind of, you know,
they don't know that you're doing well. Yeah. You, but you're like,
you're like one, two levels, like beyond, you know, like in fight club when,
you know, will this movie fight club where like, yeah. You know,
when he's at the restaurant he sees it that the two black guys,
his broken nose and he trusts them more. He's like, he gives him the nod,
but a known portion. It's like pro, who's this guy with two black eyes,
broken nose, chafed arms, all this stuff. Who is this guy? He's a Weirdo.
He's doing weirdo stuff. He's doing deviant stuff, that's for sure.
So you don't want that. You don't want that on the surface is what I'm saying,
even though you like it. So basically what you're saying is get a,
get a rash card from the Jocko store so that you're not weird to other people.
That's what I just heard. Correct. Just to break it down correctly.
Also subscribe to the podcast. Uh, as I was, uh, my kids,
my children, they were,
they were going off about some social media thing and they like smash the like
button.
I laugh because my daughter says the same thing.
So I'm going to tell you right now, if you're a little younger profile,
what I'm trying to say is smash the subscribe button through. Don't,
don't say that. Don't try to say that, don't you?
I just said I don't think you should go into that.
It falls right in, right into the a
share like, and subscribe if you want. It's, it's more,
you know what? I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm going to embrace that.
I'm gonna embrace that right now. Share like, and subscribe. Share like,
and subscribe.
Share like it's mine so we shouldn't it be acceptable that I'm like smash the
like button yet should no, no.
Cause it's like white. Wait, why I'm not going to do it. Just cause you said it,
it should be more of like a reminder. Right? Like if I was all motivational,
like you know what? You should do that like button. You got to smack that thing.
Alright. They don't worry about it. We're just kidding. Whatever.
If you want to subscribe to it, subscribe. If subscription is available,
we'll say that just by clicking the button. Don't worry about smashing.
If you're gonna Smash something,
smash your next workout or don't worry about the like button.
Don't worry about the subscribe button. Smash a metcon. How's that?
Dang, that was good. That was actually really good. Anyway also. Yes.
A warrior kid podcast too. Let's not forget about,
let's never forget it. Never. It's, it's hibernating a little bit. Sure.
Some people have been to commenting now. Yeah.
Somebody posted a picture of like someone that was like undead.
The warrior kid podcast is by no means dead.
It lives on and since I have just wrapped up a major project,
I will have some time hopefully before certain people are not available to
record. To record. Yeah. So there'll be some more common, yeah.
Good podcast. And actually that Kinda is important to note because you know,
if they're like, hey, yeah, it's done, then they won't even,
it won't be on their mind. No one's even on the lookout for it.
Then he could go on notice when it doesn't come back.
Nonetheless it's going to come back cause it's doesn't have to come back.
It's there right now. We'll listen to an episode that's not, that's there.
Alright, cool. Some people are just discovering that warrior kid podcasting.
I dig it anyway. We're used to going to where your kids Aiden's making,
so that's right. But a goat milk.
Various other ingredients in America by the way.
Irish oaks ranch.com is where you can get a trooper soap and Jocko. So wait,
does it still have the trooper soap or was that just a special edition? Yeah,
man. And that's legit. No one's on a rope, but yeah. And what's the slogan? I,
I'd say the slogan you said, but we've been, let me go ahead.
The slogan is simply stay clean. There you go. Outstanding.
Uh,
we have a youtube channel and what we would like is for you to smash the,
Hey, we got a youtube channel. If you want to watch the youtube videos,
if you're not getting inundated with enough youtube videos,
wasting your time watching videos of street fights,
watching videos of car crashes,
watching videos of acrobatic people climbing around in the city.
Oh, the park world. You know what's funny?
It's like you're just totally putting yourself on report about all the videos
here. For sure. These are the things like, oh,
you like to watch street five videos.
The thing is youtube knows what you like to watch.
So it just puts up a three on one jujitsu involved.
I'm like, oh, somebody, somebody made that video for me.
So what I'm saying is subscribe to the Youtube Channel if you want to see the
videos that we put out.
Otherwise go watch some more drunk girl fails.
I don't really watch that one, but I will watch like fast tactical reloads.
So anyways, there you go. Boom. There it is. Yeah. Tube.
Also psychological warfare. If you don't know what that is,
it's an album with tracks of Jocko telling you how to get past moments of
weakness if they may arise, if they may arise. I went to a,
I didn't go to the donut shop. I passed it.
There's a bank and there's a donut shop right by where it isn't that weird that
doughnut shops exist. They don't anymore.
That was going to be my 0.3 people in there. The lady in there, you winning.
We're winning. We're going to win. I even heard a,
what do you call Krispy Kremes is like either out of business or going out of
business, like, I don't know, record rate or something like that. But men,
the lady in the donut shop was um,
on her laptop in one of the customer like tables on the seat, you know,
it was, she wasn't behind the counter on and she was just coming in here. Yeah.
No one's coming here at awesome. Dang. Anyway,
what should they replace all donut shops with steak houses?
Yeah. Well. Yeah, I guess there's less chances. Jujitsu studios?
Yeah, just like a vacant, you know what?
They should do a vacant building. They clear out all the donut, uh,
material and machines.
I don't know how you make donuts but clear out all that stuff.
You just put one like a mat space, one mat space. That's it.
[inaudible] paper and a pencil. You just sign your name. Boom. I came in,
use this, met me and my partner. Boom. Sure. Come in, leave.
I didn't really think it through,
but nonetheless psychological war for what I was saying.
This album tracks by Jocko. Can you through your moments,
the report says that that psychological warfare,
the album has done massive damage to the donut industry apparently is what's
going on. That's what I'm hearing. Yes.
Big Time evidently is if you don't want the audio version of that,
but you want a visual version, you can check out flip side,
canvas.com run by my brother Dakota Meyer and he makes things for you to hang on
your wall,
high quality things for you to hang on your wall to remind you of what it is
that you're doing here.
So check it out if you have any suggestions or you can hit up Dakota on social
media and tell them what you want to see. So there you go. Flip side,
campus.com also on it is a good one.
Fun at.com/jockos where you can get your kettlebells, your battle ropes,
various fitness equipment. This is good. You could also get socks.
Didn't seem like it. I know and I've said it before. He gets socks, socks,
socks or a thing I guess. Well I, you know,
I'm one of those guys who I kinda like cool socks.
I don't buy them all the time,
but I don't know what kind of guy likes cool socks. I don't know, it's just,
but there's a whole industry out there used to be and for me it's still is socks
means one thing. Pair of white socks. That's what socks means. Yeah.
Well you're, you and I don't have it. Darth Vader socks like you do or whatever.
No, I've Darth Vader kettlebells, but no, nothing. No. Dan,
where'd you get the Darth Vader kettlebells from on it? Of course.
Cause they got Darth Vader, they've got iron man.
They got some good ones on there also.
They have like the thing called an elk bar.
It's the same thing as a warrior bar, but it's made an elk high in protein.
Really good. Like a um, almost like big beef jerky sticks. Good.
You might get that. A lot of good stuff on there. A on it.com/jocko.
You'd like something, get something. Also,
we've got some books that the books that were written by John Striker Meyer,
the books, but written by tilt. You can get those on Amazon across the fence.
The secret war in Vietnam on the ground,
the secret war in Vietnam and SOG chronicles volume one.
Check those books out there. They're really amazing to read especially,
and they're kind of books that when you read them,
you have to actually slow down. Think about what the hell is actually going on,
man. Because when you think about what's actually going on,
you'll realize that the,
what these guys were doing was just absolutely completely insane.
So check out those books. Also check out,
weigh the warrior kid three where there's a will.
That book is live and ready for you to read or for ready for your kids.
Read also got way the
warrior kid won the and way the warrior kid two marks. Mission.
These are good books to get kids on the path.
All those little things that you want kids to know,
but they don't really listen to you because you're their parent.
This is the ultimate flank. And if you listen to JP Denelle,
he says that these warrior kid books are a flank on the parent to thing.
Yet they are 100% as is Mikey and the dragons,
which is a book for kids to learn how to overcome fear.
So check those out. Then we've got the discipline equals freedom field manual,
which will tell you how to get after it. You don't need to ask.
You can just get the manual. Well that'd be nice. Yeah. Oh, it's true.
It is nice. Yes. You get that field manual and you're good to go.
If you want the audio version of it, it's on iTunes, Amazon music,
Google play and other MP3 platforms.
And then of course you've got extreme ownership and that dichotomy of
leadership.
The two books that I wrote with my brother Leif Babin talking about everything
that we've learned in combat and how you can take those lessons and you can
utilize them with your business, with your team,
with your life. So check those out. Also, we've got echelon front.
That's my leadership consultancy.
And what we do is solve problems through leadership.
Every problem that exists in your organization is a leadership problem.
So if you need help fixing that leadership problem and thereby fixing the
problems that you have inside your organization,
go national on front.com if you [inaudible]
need further instruction, if you want something beyond this podcast,
if you want to come to the muster,
the monster is a leadership training seminar,
I guess I'd call it.
It's a leadership convention and what we do is go deep dive,
get granular on leadership.
The next one is September 19th and 20th in Denver and then after that it's
December 4th and fifth in Sydney, Australia, every single we've done seven,
they've all sold out. These are going to sell out too, so if you want to come,
go to extreme ownership.com and sign up and if you can't come to that,
you can go to EMF online.com and that's our leadership training,
interactive online platform where you can get the skills,
you can reinforce the skills, the skills that I talk about on this podcast,
the skills that we wrote about in the books.
Those skills need further training all the time.
You never master these things, so go to Yaffe online.com and check that out.
And then there's of course GF Overwatch where we've been taking proven leaders,
tested leaders from special operations and from combat aviation and putting them
into companies in the civilian sector that need leadership.
So if you're looking to hire,
don't always hire just because someone has experience,
hire for character,
hire for leadership capability and then you teach them this,
the industry specifics because that's easier than trying to teach someone
character. We're trying to teach someone leadership,
the f overwatch.com if you need leadership and if you want to converse with us
further,
then we are on the interwebs all on Twitter,
on Instagram and on that show face you boy hush.
Okay,
echo is that Echo Charles. I Imad, Jocko Willink and
John Stryker Meyer is at
John Stryker Meyer and once again,
thanks to John Striker Meyer, 22 years old,
putting his life on the line over and over and over again for our freedom and to
those of you in uniform right now,
putting your lives on the line for our freedom.
Thank you for being there for us.
And the same thing goes for our police and law enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and EMT ts and dispatchers and correctional officers and border
patrol and secret service and all forced for first responders out there.
You put your lives on the line to keep us safe and we thank you for it.
And to everyone else out there,
you might be scared and you might be tired in,
you might be surrounded by the enemy who is preparing to attack,
but you know what? You're still alive.
So get the high ground,
set up your perimeter lock and load your weapons and go get after it.
And until next time,
this is eco and Jocko out.